Hey?
I'm a dreamer even though we're a kitty cat.
Cat, I'm a kitty cat.
And I meow, meow, meow.
Cat, I'm a kitty cat, and I dance, dance, dance.
And I dance, dance, dance.
Cat, I'm a kitty cat.
You guys remember that hit viral YouTube video where the song goes
I'm a cat, me and I'm a kitty cat
And I dance and dance and dance and dance and dance
Yeah, well I remember anyway
I don't know if it might be better for me to play games like in the middle of the screen
I feel like I'll always cover up something important over here
But then I end up getting really tiny, but then if I'm here, it's like well
At least I can show my face
I can't feel my face when I'm open
Heart or heart?
Okay, let me explain the hearts
I did a bit of, did a bit of work, yeah
Did a bit of work
So you may notice
Good morning
Good evening
Or good afternoon
I'm your host
Strony Cuttos
Let's get right into the updates
Which is hardly any, there's not that much interesting stuff
If you are a member of any viewer member, you may notice that there's hearts
What do the hearts mean?
The hearts are placeholders for where emotes are going to go
YouTube is slightly, slightly
A little bit, dare I say, a bit based
You cannot lose an emotes slot if you bagzian, okay
I'm gonna hope that bagzian is a terminology
Used by anyone else outside of Scotland
But bagzian means it is reserved, if you will
My new favourite emotes just dropped, okay
Can we keep one heart or moe?
Although I think me holding the heart and moe is better than just an emote
Bro, I can't even fucking png them
But anyway, if you are a member of any girls channel, you will notice that there's moe slots
And depending on how many hearts you see is how many slots unlocked
AC for example is the first girl to receive her batch
So hers is already up
Emmys is the next to receive her batch
There was a bit of a miscommunication error
And by miscommunication error, they just randomly didn't draw one of the emotes we requested
And drew one of the emotes we already, like redrew one of the emotes we already had
And they were like, here's your delivery
And I was like, no, no, no, no, that's not what my little sister wanted
And that has to be, I'm glad she caught it actually
I sent it to Emmys and I was like, how does it look?
Are you happy with it?
And she's like, strongy, there's an entire emote missing
And one we didn't ask for, and I'm like, you know what Emmys?
Even though you have negative 5 prescription, you've got some bloody good eyes on you sometimes for spotting
Eh, oh did you hear my caller?
Hi, hi, hello, hello
I can't go anywhere
Um, updates
There's a new AC short, there's a new short on my channel
There's a new short on Mercy's channel
Um, Azura's got 4 shorts that have been ordered
One of them is absolutely outrageous and hilarious
Um, I had to get a serial box commissioned for it
It was that funny
Um, so hopefully when that comes out, I'll send Azura's way
Cause Purser and Sheebie haven't had any shorts love
But finally, the shorts are working out and you know, people are ready to work on them
Oh Anonymous tipped me, hold on a minute, we have missed your tipped Anonymous
Give us the tip
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Thank you for giving us so many streams to share with you
Some of us are less active, but no less appreciative of how much you do
Ah, don't you worry, you bumberino, gibberino, schnibberino, woobberino
Anonymous, you don't have to fucking look
I know it's not easy to keep up with me every single day, you know
For mummies got endurance, the way we like it around here, okay?
Thank you very much for the tip, that's very kind of you
And yes, I'm glad you can enjoy the daily content
Speaking of daily content, uh...
We're still on for daily streams, that's the good news
We're having a few health issues, okay?
So currently, oh I just realized I'm linking the ACSR
We're currently having some mild issues with health
That is, I basically, I go for a nap for four hours when I finish a stream
And then four hours before a stream, I'm having a nap, I'm not having a full sleep
And I had a dream about a VTuber that I haven't even met and don't exist before
So the lines are getting crossed, I'm fucking dreaming about VTubers
That aren't even real!
I'm gonna start fighting real sh- I'm doing Shadow Boxing for real
In my head, in my head, in my head
Is it Army? Army, Army
I don't know what that song is
So I'm starting to hallucinate a wee bit
Not quite at the hallucinatory stage, however
I am really struggling to wake up for streams
But my only other alternative option
Oh is it Zombie? No, what did I say? Army
Zombie, in my head, in my head
Zombie, zombie
Anyway, whilst I'm being distracted
We're playing a game called Stray
Apparently it takes five hours to do this game
Everyone went absolutely coconuts when this game dropped
I personally have not played it before
But it's got cats in it
And you know how we do around these parts
If you didn't know, Wham and Love It
When men like creatures or lesser beings
Because it shows that man is safe
If man does not like creature or lesser being
Man is not safe
Hmm, Monca es
But apparently we get to be a yin-yor cat
As well, not just any kind of cat, a yin-yor
Five hours if you're quick
Oh no
Oh my god
Why are we so skinny?
We need to fatten us up
Where's your primordial pouch?
Oh my god
Hello
Oh actually, I'm ginger
Wait, whoa, that camera's a bit...
Oh my god, Mia
Do you jump?
Jump
No
Oh no
Hello
Oh my god
It's Chateau Noir
Bonjour Chateau Noir
Hello
Oh, I'm the submissive cat
Do you know why?
Because I got licked on the face
So I'm the submissive putter
Okay, ginger is the submissive
Hey, but you're a mix
You're a calico-colo-colo-lolo cat
Oh, we're all playing
Yeah, we buddy
Oh, we're getting a little scent marking
On that one
Hello
Oh my god
Oh, I'm the submissive one
Out of all of them
I guess the runt is a litter
That's okay
Oh my god, are we going to sleep as a family?
Oh, can I come join?
Oh my god, we can sleep together as a family
Oh my god
I loved this game already
Cat-fine box, sitting box
Yeah
But yes, the love hearts are going to get swapped out
Oh, look at Mia, old ginger and stuff
I'm ginger tabby
Aw, yeah, look at my ginger tabby
It's a booty fly
Oh, we're flicking her ear
That's so cute
Tell me if the game is a bit too loud, okay?
Because you know me, terrible for balancing my voice
And then in-game audio
Oh, let me sip my tea
Remember that time I read out everyone's interview
On acapella media in a magazine
Because they were kind enough to let them interview us
And let us be like the front page of it and everything
And then proceeded to talk
Proceeded to celebrate a refund
Giving me a bit but of 21 times
Yeah, god, I remember
Jeez, I'm so sorry
Please continue to talk to us
Fucking
I will say one thing, acapella media were like
At the end of it
They were like
If you've got any other news you'd like to report on
Please let us know
And I'm like, oh my god, that's so kind
What the heck?
So we can literally submit like
Interests and stuff that's happening
Which is really nice
Like they were so nice
Like shout out to them
Because they weren't like, eee
Your whole bags were no interview
And you were not in getaway
Eee
Beee
They weren't like that
They were just like, ah, it's a girl
Oh my god, we're so agile
Now, don't get me wrong
I don't want to say my perceptions off or anything
But either no humans are here
Or we're post-apocalyptic cause
Oh, chateau noir
Bonjour, chateau noir
Comment tu t'appelles?
Oh, we're zooming in
Oh, those are spiky concrete
Steel bars and concrete
Um, well, give me a second
I'm drinking my tea though
What happens?
Can we like explore areas and stuff?
Or is it alpha?
Oh, alpha to jump
Okay, wee
Alright, stop
Stop me on
Alright, go on
Let's go
Ta-da, men
I'm trying to finish my tea
The camera's like quite snappy
I don't know if that makes any sense
Press Bravo
I'm barking with B
Hello
Are we French cats?
No, the black one's French
He's called Chat Noir
Wherever he is
There he is
That's Chat Noir
Oh, my God
The white one
You're...
I'm not giving you a name
But this one's called
Calical, calical, calical
You can hit me below
Like Calico or something
That's the type they're called, I think
The white one
He's got two sports on his tail
So we'll call him two sports, polka dots
Two sports, polka dots
It's Chat Noel and Calakity Calakity Calakity
Oh, we can like do a repause. Oh, yeah. Oh, that's that good sleep. Oh, that's that good stuff. Oh
This feels amazing on my clothes. Look how sharp they are weapons weapons. I tell you absolute weapons
Where we adventuring off to next yeah, this is given there's absolutely abandoned
Women's
I'm like no, would we really be in abandoned facility?
Oh
Honestly cats
Gimli Vigo totally not calling you's out here, but you guys do that all the effing time
I'll I give they've got what they got. They've got two water dishes
They've got one
Water fountain and they'll go out in the back garden and drink from a puddle and I'm like, you know what you know what I do not
Vigo and Gimli I
Do not in but give you the freshest of the price
Oh, thank you
What kind of name I need a cat this name. Hmm. Why are you so cool?
I'll be in
Yes, I like that but the puddle has flavor. Don't forget to knock them pain cans
I'm nervous. Oh, wow, we are agile little frickers. Okay. Do we have whoa?
Okay, I think there's like aim assist when it comes to okay. Yeah, no, it's like you can't really walk off
Okay, thank goodness. I ain't got that kind of agility. Oh, how do I run? Oh, wait, right trigger to run. Let's go
Go where are like, oh my god, me and my gang. This is like yakuza for cats
I would okay. We're playing yakuza for cats right now, right? When did we start a like
When is it cold? Is it extortion when it's like, oh, you're in my territory. You owe me one tuna can
Me and Kuzla honestly, I developed that game on our paws are getting wet icky. We don't want our paws to get wet. We're cats
Those booty flies here. Oh
Oh
Chat Noir is playing with one. Where are you going? You're going so deep into this. It's under here. Oh, okay. Oh, look guys go
Oh, I don't pretty game fold left trigger to observe
And E equals MC squared observe. Holy are we doing?
How do we even get back from where we were sleeping?
Honestly
Alpha
Oh, I'm not sure
Like I'm glad the game has like that kind of aim assist
So you can't he just jump off the map because I'm gonna be honest if it didn't it'd be over for me
Go Chat Noir. Go. Oh wait. Hold on a minute
I don't think we're this is now hold on a minute. I think my you my name cuz the game just went out the window
Oh, no
In your
In your know
Game over credits roll hello fault at full damage ouch
Oh my gosh, I was rather violent
I
Mean I won for me
My heart I must be
I'm her shit, uh, right. I need a bit mr. Vet, please. Oh, that's horrible
Oh
No, I'm gonna pass out. I don't feel good. Oh, I need rest
Furry thing
The fuck if all this was me a nice cat game
Hey, he walks with a limb like an old-school pimp a real og a real og
Oh
Um
Did we do that
I can't tell if that's in game me on or Gimli's at my door
Yeah, my
No, mommy the cat's not an engineer. Okay. I've licked my leg
No, I can't run yet whoa, so we got saved because of the garbage
My pals went home right as long as they're safe. Oh, we can run
Okay, it's too early to be
Doing enemies got a lot of enemies, so I think I'm okay just to kind of get the gist of the game. Oh
I've got an achievement missed jump fall inside the city. We are in
City do la murk whoa. Whoa. What's that? Whoa is also enemies
I will follow the light because that's how you do it in every video game
Whoa big jump big jump just for considerin, but we oh
No, it's 1984 come on. Let's take down the high tables a cat
You don't have to tell me twice
As we love you whoa
What are those bugs?
The bull were you hello?
Android
Wait, I had an a on it
Dumb with the high table honestly, I need to well
The music's changing I
Hear something whoa
Hey, hey
Hell, okay, I don't need help
Let us commence fourth to hell
That just hold a oh if I hold a
She keeps going. Okay. I wonder if I'm a sheer
I'm a yin you're that oh
Wait, something's asking for my help can something see me hello
Hi
What are you a bucket what would I need to do with a bucket?
It's something thirsty. I need to nourish something. Oh
I'm such a smart kitty
Hello. Oh wait, this is the paint you told me about
Yeah, fuck that pain. Yeah, fuck the pain
What's that someone paid money and resources? What's with the CC? Oh the CCTV cameras the person that can see me, okay?
I'm guessing I need to jump over here. Can you make that jump hooters? Oh my gosh, you're like we're lagging but you're doing it
Yeah, forget that pain. Oh you stink
Oh
Am I going down that way? Oh, no, there's glass. I've just created though. I think it is
Please land carefully buddy, okay, don't do it don't do it follow me I read that
And then you oh, there's a carpet. What did I do with it? Oh
My god, fuck it up tear it up tear it up. Oh, oh, oh tear it up
Okay, maybe I need to get out of the way in the middle. I think I'm covering up the putters doing stuff. Hold on
Okay, we'll go in the corner. I think there's anything happening
Stop, okay. Oh
This is like proper actually, okay. I'm coming. I don't know. Oh, there's another thing I can tear up the couch
Oh, no, I was gonna tear up the couch. Great. How'd I get that?
Oh
Don't water. Yeah, let's hydrate me feel better after getting some water in towards my brother needs your help
Oh, yeah, there's two emmy shorts as well sense floors are off and Phoebe's got batch next
Okay, we're all hydrated now we can do one big peeler allegation
Oh
Is this a oh my gosh, I'm so smart. I don't even have poseable thumbs. I'm like the smartest cat
Yeah, I don't enemies are others friendly. I seem to be scaring them wherever they are
Go up. What?
They don't seem that scary whatever they are they seem friendly it well, they just seem to
know
Hello
Oh, I slow our time in one go
When strony hydrae is more in game than in real life, honestly though
Parkour and dead came up on no wonder this game go game of the year nominee and
It's a game of the year nominee
I
Did not know that
They were up
Let's go game of the year. I
I
remember a
Big I remember full
Going absolutely mental when it came out
I think his name when knew what was going on with it like it just dropped out of nowhere or it felt like it dropped out
No, we're like oh by the way you can be a
I'm in the wrong neighborhood. Oh
No, okay, okay, okay, okay, whoa
Oh, no, don't the freaking cut scene. Okay, they're enemies. They are enemies. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. What did I do?
Just keep running oh
Bravo Bravo evasive maneuvers evasive maneuvers evasive maneuvers. Okay. I'm just running running running running
Oh
Bravo Bravo Bravo I repeat I repeat I like jumping stuff. No, I can't I can only run
This is a terrible
How many is there you guys are unending?
I'm not gonna get a gun to protect myself. I'm pressing B as much as I can
I'm not getting a gun to protect myself. I'm supposed to win this game
Give me a gun right now a key 47 give me give me give you the most time in Sally. Come on. Let's go
You can't do that. Oh
Geez
Oh, you've a itching them off of us whatever they were stinky follow me. Where are you?
We
Break something
Yeah, we're prepped we've weaved back and forth and it it's slightly easier to evade them curious
We're ready to go. I'm not late. It doesn't really look like it
No, I don't see it
Up on that cage. Oh
I like okay, follow the light follow the light. I will follow the light. You know what I will
We're done you on the paper
Follow the light. I'm
Following I'm good at following in structure. I'm so smart. I really
Plank bonk
I
Follow
Serpentine Serpentine tears go out there everywhere
Follow the light. Hello. I am in a laundry mat any laundry matters
I can't jump
Let me jump this week
I
Okay, that's kind of a cool mechanic. Oh
Wait if I meow he gives me help
If you meow the game tells you what to do that's so oh hi again. Is it him that's watching me?
It must be I'm getting watched by someone who am I helping?
I
Sorry if I spin anyone around
I got some
This game is pretty clever when it comes to gating the player
I mean, that's my kind of game look. I'm a yellow paint game. Oh
Not again again. Oh
I was late, we've only just recovered from one fall. Let's not go again
Yes, I am I am big fan of the yellow paint sorry, I don't folks any like the yellow paint
But I do I'm too dumb and daft. Okay. Well, that's a big boy jump. Can you make that?
And we make it
We have a plank though, how do I get up there? Can you make it up there?
clever, I don't know what you are
I
Want to say it's a guy cat, but kind of looks a bit. It looks like a guy cat from the body
So yinya is a dude look at the door
This game is so awesome. You enjoyed your trip. No cuz I'm frickin
misplaced my pals, right?
Can I even jump oh
I'm so I'm such a skinny legend as a cat honestly like this
Yeah, I'm over here
Okay, I'm uh-huh. Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm. Oh, yeah
Hello
Another we're getting there
Exploration game
Oh
Okay, I'm not dead end no
This is a dead end bro
Huh oh skinny legend. Ah, excuse me there. I was like, oh
Why oh
It's a power thingy lights are on but literally I
I do kind of wish the initial fall wasn't a cut scene you just dropped as soon as you went for it
Just to really humble you as a cat. Oh, yeah, get right your rubbish cat. Oh
We're in a flat
We're in like the next chapter already
Cuz oh
I would check to my marshmallow this morning and a poor leafland was like I can't handle your shorter streams
It's so quiet you when you go and I'm like, oh my god, you're in for a terrible couple of weeks
Yeah
Need help. Oh, what's wrong?
All right. Oh, here we go. Let me help you. Okay
They are corrupted need help. Okay, don't worry. I've got the code. I'm in boys. Let me just finish typing it for you
Enter the door turn on find a body
Um, wait our cats
Can cats read or is this just by chance this cat is mucking about a
Secret room secret room. Oh, what's for you? I know you're dead computer. You're not like
Sister jump off. Oh
There's oh, I just turned off
Unless
Accidentally stumbling my way into doing things. Oh, yeah
Okay, we need three more power boxes
Cats can't read strongy, but how did how did I accidentally do the right thing like is a month a month smarty-pants?
Right, there's nothing here that I can pull out. There's a lever. Oh
I found one
main now
Let me just pop in there
I'm looking oh big one up there. Hold on. How'd I get up? Oh
Big jump
Big big jump. Oh
And I'm on the table. Hold on honey and jump down darlin
Come on. We in here and you need to jump down
Oh
Puzzle time is actually stop if it's a puzzle. Oh, I can see it
There's like a little crosshair where it's sitting on it. So I'm not actually having to
Use my brain, thank you
Right, so the but there's gonna be a body after this
You know for a cat to stumble upon this
Uh
We're doing a body. Oh my god. He died in VR. Oh
I thought I had to interact with it. Oh, I just took off his head
This isn't it this isn't the interaction I thought the game wanted me to
Is that see well, it's an item. It's an item in this room
I'm looking
Yeah, interactive with the body. They're there ain't nothing to interact with he's gone. There's a box up here though
Oh wait jump on to the platform of the box. Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Pardon me. Excuse me. Sorry for using your car
What are you why get off that shelf
Put it in the body no just a jump out
What does that say?
Zoel zoel rep Zoel you will be missed
I
I'm stuck in this room. So I can't go anywhere. Oh
Oh, Aros are pointing. Okay. I love this game. Literally holding my hand
Neko Johnny isn't real. Oh
Hold on a minute
Hold on. Nope. Oh, wait, hold on actually
Don't and don't guess what I'm about to do either or I'm actually gonna be raging
Don't guess what I'm about to do either or I will be so mad. Do I make myself clear? Don't guess what I'm about to do
I'm doing
Oh no
Hold on
Hold on. Hold on. This is awful. I don't reverse it
I don't reverse it
Flip image. Okay. Okay. There we go. Okay. Uh-huh
Okay
Speaking of pussy cat
Meow motherfucker
Meow. Okay. It's a wee bit wonky, but you know what? I tried my best
I tried my best. Oh, what's happening?
We've got a lot of robot
Johnny Neko, it's your
Would you still love me if I was a Neko Vtuber?
Meow
You wonder Gimli's gonna say mad if I'm going
Oh
Oh, no, I kill uh, I did every bit technology I touch just perishes
Bonk bonk
I'm on yin here. Oh, he's up again. He's up. He's up. Oh, we've gone
Uh
Next language, please
It worked. I'm free. Thank you. Oh, are you the buddy talking to me as long as you keep your Scottish accent meow motherfucker
I couldn't believe the cameras. I can't in the dead city. I
I can't remember my name. It seems my memory's corrupted
I've been trapped in the network for so long
I know I worked for a scientist who lived here for now. You can call me b12. That's what it says on my exterior
Huh, it's dangerous in the dead city, but you seem like you know how to handle yourself. Let's get out of here. Follow me
Yesterday, there was a Jesse role play now we get me out tomorrow. We have James
James is a man
Let's follow me. Okay. I will follow you. I will follow you
The keys unlock the door. I remember that much. Yep. Let me get that for you. Thank you
I will follow you
Very good battery low already come over here. Okay
Follow you forever
You
You're gonna have to put this on. Okay
Are you putting clothes on a cat? No, you're oh
Yeah, I'm not surprised. Yeah, you're not supposed to put clothes on a cat. They can't walk on cool. Oh my gosh
He hates it yinnyo. It's okay. I think it's okay yinnyo yinnyo. You're gonna be fine. You're so dramatic
This backpack was designed for small quadrupeds like yourself
Is this uncomfortable for you? Don't worry. You'll get used to it. I'm digitized the key and stored it in the backpack. Okay
Press up to open your infant door
Easy if you're ever curious about an object you can just show it to me or to others if you come across any now
Let's get out of this flat
Oh British development team. Okay. Wait. I'm used to the backpack already. All right. Let's go
Key here open
Key use icon
Oh, yeah
Press use a torch. Whoa
Use a digit code
We don't have one
uh
Give us a thank me code code in here
Uh
Code oh, yeah, yeah code, uh three
Three seven four eight three seven four eight three seven four eight
three
Seven four eight. Oh my god. I'm sorry
I have to like sing it to myself to remember or it's not happening
You're laughing the cat is uncomfortable and you're just laughing
Whoa, look at this place that elevator in the distance. I think that's important
Oh, yes. Yes. I know we need to go up. Okay. I believe your words funny, man. Let's go
Um
It looks like those bugs that we're chasing us are a bit more powerful than we first anticipated because
What is that?
Uh, not good. It's uh, this is uh niche niche board nine nine
Group them together like 37 and then 48 much easier like that. Oh, I see that
I don't think
Wait, I remember the outside wait you're uh
Uh
It feels like I've been there for boards. That's where you've came from. No, I didn't come from a sandy shore
I promise someone I would go there promise to what to the Bahamas
Are you humans stuck in a ball this postcard the mural was painted from it. Let's take it sure
I
Next I have gained why do I have these memories? How did they get here? Let's keep going
Hmm, you're I thought this game was about being a cat. We're about to like try and discover someone's like memories
I hear noises or is it him that's making noises
Okay, follow the light I'm following the light. Don't worry. I've got this
No, no, you don't need to go in the dumpster. There's a little bucket there. Yeah, go in the bucket
If you know the flesh that meets, you know
Oh
Give me that get run what are you doing jump up jump jump up. Oh my god. No, we're not doing this
Oh, there's a human save us. There's a wee bug after us mate mate. There's a bug after us
Hello
I'm a pictures
Relax, I'm just a putter. I'm a putty cat
What's this?
Whoa
Wait, they're scared of a little pudder. I can't even speak English the only reason I understand anything
It's because of a robot right now. Are you limping away from me as if I'm chasing you?
Yeah
Center track is a little funky. Oh don't need to lower the game volume. Sorry
Literally terrified. Is it called like necrophobia if you're absolutely like terrified of a cat?
Um, oh no, I just realized I look at discord can end me now
Um
Putters what's that cats are called in scotland putters p u d d e r s a putters a little putter kit a little putty cat
You guys don't say putters
Hello discord kitten. Hello zany
Me
They seem to have their own language
You're no zerk any give them the good suck. Um, we're not familiar with your kind. Well
Uh, I'm not much of a threat either
You're welcome in our village as long as you don't eat it
That look like I'll be eating stuff other than tuna
The fear of cats is called
Ileurophobia
Discord ASMR incoming
Um discord ASMR might be funny if I put on a really harsh accent like
Oh daddy, please buy me discord nitro. Please daddy
I'd love if you bought me discord nitro
Oh, and maybe buy me the pink mercy skin and the new valorant pink skin
Like that
I made some progress with my collaborations yesterday. I've got two more scripts to make and then
Are you oh, you're resting. They're all asleep. Should I leave them to sleep?
I kind of want to talk to you
Oh
Other meditating
Why go up there there's nothing there
Well, you're not very supportive of my adventures
Can I go up here to see it? No, I guess not and game said no
You're lost. What do you need? I don't even know what I need. Um
This fellow seems to know a lot about the area tutorial really said go talk to him
Should we show him the postcard? Maybe he knows a way out here
Show him a postcard
Left
Stick show postcard show idol. Oh a picture of outside ridiculous the elevator isn't operational
Everyone knows that it is impossible to leave this place. Well except outsiders, but they're all gone now except momo
You can try and talk to him if you want, but he gave up on trying to leave. It's for the best
He lives up high in that building with the orange neon sign
Well, we have our heading. I mean, it's not but it's four hundred and thirty dollars for a random freaking skin on leak
Oh, that actually sounds a bit hilarious. Yeah, you like that
price isn't to ask b12 for help
I'm to go up to him
Um
Okay, what do you say b12 tell us give us a new don't hesitate to call me i'm here at help if you want me
Call me
If you want to beat me the guardian told us to talk to momo in the high building
Okay, right, so he's just going to tell you the mission objective. So what's this? Is this just like stuff you can do?
Coca cola. He's too much actually hydration check. Can we get cola in real life?
Oh, we can energy drink speed to key
I
Never know inventory. Okay, curious
Meet
Hello, i'm the musician, but I don't have any song
Honestly, when you said that I felt like that. I like literally yesterday navi waves from zelda
micro transactions and then
Pirate shit
Shit
Uh, only seem at three times one of the friends of the cheapest version
If people actually buying four hundred dollar skins, who's got that kind of money to go and speck electrical cable and speck question work
Hello, i'm a merchant of the market. Yeehaw
You give me something i'll give you something
Bartering system. Let's go. This is an ancient relic a testament to the talent of our ancestors
free energy drink
That's a bit the cat
Waiting for you to open it so I can then walk back inside the house. I don't find a go out
honestly
Gimli's like that all the time and speck sheet music. Oh
For the artist that wants it. This is the music a master piece of art for a renowned artist
Wait, so then what do I need cable for or is this just
Best on the market. I'll exchange it for a super spirit detergent. That's the best I can do right
We'll give the music man his music
Sure yes, uh take this
Eagle thank you new item gained. Okay. We're going back to the music man. I am the music man. I play the piano
No
Oh, wait, we can run. Sorry. I forgot. I forgot. I just been polite. You know, you're not supposed to run in the city
Hello, I have music for you. Talk with more uski
Oh, you don't have any music you'll never guess what this neckl has for you
The way you compute tonight. Oh, that's a nice one. Hear me out. Okay
Oh
Do we like it I sense almost halloween is
I'm a cat in the city and I'm lost and I'm pretty and I'm cat in the city and I'm lost in the
Um
Jump over here and I run away from enemies and lose the robots all around me, but I'm safe
And I'm happy and I'm dry and got tuna and my tummy
Uh
Thank you
But I don't have posable paws
Uncle uncle
I loved it again again again. Okay. We go up
It looks bright over here. So this is my only indication going up
Shawnee was feeling it. I'm a cat in the city. I'm meowing so pretty
I'm a ginger cat and the way I walk and the way I squawk I'm coming
For some
I fell down a hole and I wasn't feeling hot now I'm eating some kind of big robot you look
Like a little zerk from a far away. Oh, is the zerk the enemies?
They look and sound cute, but don't be fooled those things truth. They're metal metal
Um
Oh my god, there's bars
For the song thank you
Thank you glass
Um, yeah, you leave a little made up song on the spot
A
Duffer bar does that mean does duffer? Oh, oh, it's the Bahama picture. Hello
Oh
Uh
I accidentally stumbled one two eight three
Excuse me
My apologies, but this isn't osha approved if you're allowing me to walk all over. Do you have any drinks?
What did the drink? What does that blue one say it says robot oil this?
Hi
Oh, can I just go under here? I was gonna say I'm so tiny. Hello America. Hi
You're new around here. What can I do for you? Um
Nothing right now right one two eight three
It's not gonna be the jukebox
One two eight, three. Oh, good. Is he just gonna let me go upstairs?
He's like, hmm this random thing. I've never seen before that's tiny one
Two eight three. I'm so gonna forget this code before I find wherever I'm supposed to impose it
Uh, you're not an input site. Where is the input code section?
But they're here
No, this is leaving
Okay, someone put the code in chat. Thank goodness. Where are they? Remember
Do they really consume this their original design doesn't have a digestive tract
Maybe they somehow evolved to mimic humans. Do they think I should try some of it? I don't want to be disrespectful of them
So you eat
So the robots eat
Oh, can I do it? Wait, hold on. Let me line it up. Let me let hold easy steady
No, you no ahead. I lined it up. No
Not my first freaking movie in that. Oh, they have oh can I score?
Oh my god classic. Oh my god. Can I score all of these?
Of course my first move is to put the main one in the freaking hole
Can you get more me than that? Then you go. All right one more
Doesn't matter what hole you go in as long as you're going. Yeah, we did it. We won
Oh, no, the black one goes last. Whoops. I know take sheet music. Oh
We can get an uncle. Oh my god. Let's go get another song. Hold on
I know there's probably a cool thing that's really important
But we must speak to the man who sings the songs
I hope you're ready for another Jew another super awesome song. Hi buddy. Hello
Yeah, I can find more you'll never guess what I have
Tomorrow's sounds cool here. Watch this
Oh slowly I go on the little road is long
But that's okay because tomorrow I'll see you. I can't see you every day, but that's okay
Because another day away means another day with you
Another day away and it just means tomorrow is that day
It's changing a bit, but we're trying. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
We love it. We need more sheet music like right now. I don't know how to find oh wait
What was the code
What was it one two three eight
One two eight three. Oh, sorry one two eight three
No way we randomly keep oh my music music music music. Okay. Okay next song next song. What's it called?
What's it called? We have our prompt
Whatever the name of the song is is the prompt. Hello
Yeah, you'll get your practice in where can I find more and what's this called?
Unreadable music sheet. Oh no
Okay, okay, let's go. Let's go try
Even if I can't
Even if I can't understand I'll still try my best every day
This one's kind of hard to do. I can't really sing to it
Please stop singing
Okay, sorry. Sorry, right. We'll back up right. We we did our thing. Okay. Uh, what do we need to do?
So there's some sort of barter system down here. Um
Someone seems to be digging in the trash, right? We need to go up to this gentleman up here
um
The siren that can't sing literally
Uh, wait, how 100 super spirit power
Oh, no, he's angry at me. I'm sorry
Uh, right up up up. Let's see
Uh, uh, if it's up then it's up then it's up
So right up up up up. Where is this gentleman?
gentlemen
This is democracy manifest, right? What's going on up here me? Oh, hello
Those aren't stars I've seen anytime soon
The circles of light are pleasing to watch but I want to see the real sky one day
You want to go on an adventure buddy?
What's going on? We're tossing paint cans
Hello, what do I do? It says why?
Okay, I didn't I'm to meow whilst they're tossing cans to one another
Interesting let me try to figure it well done. Look
She's a siren who can't sing please keep singing
Strongly the man doesn't speak for us that's singing this one. Yeah, you're like when it's terribly out of tempo and I have no idea
That one guy got good
Oh
I hope he doesn't lose his job
Wait, so now go down again
Down no kitty down. Well, yeah, no you can go down this way
Okay, so I have glued the ground
Hello
I can talk to you now. Why are you so oh you're mangy
He mad and angry. He mangy. I'm cleaning the porch of my shop again
Stop playing over my shop. You clumsy rascal
Racine frasman
What's this? It's a laundromat. Well do robots need laundry you done?
What is it?
Okay, I've unlocked something but there's nothing in here
What is this oh
take
Oh, that's what the guy wanted for wires. So don't eat
Thank you for letting us yoink a few things. Are you okay, buddy? Oh, you're in it. Oh, he's a cowboy, baby
Oh, well at least cosmos making me use of all of making use of all that detergent. Okay
Right, let's go treat the wire person because apparently stealing it's more like borrowing
than actually stealing
Because look we're getting an item out of it inspect the electrical cables. What do you want? Uh, I set uh, yep
Yep, I you'll never guess why am I just picked up all yours, buddy. Okay, what do I do with it though?
I think and then this
I don't know if that's just a memory unlock. It doesn't really seem like I need it
So you're the borrower type
What a little kleptomaniac
You just sound like mr. Krabs
Barterman super spirit laundry grandma's clothing what ways grandma's clothing the third one
Elliot's programming
I've smoked a bar or spoke to thingy. Yeah, so we'd go speak to are you nope. You're not grandma. Are you grandma?
Nope, you're a bar
grandma
Wait, I need some clothes some naked. I know I've got fur, but that doesn't count translate
I
Elliot's programming knock the door and wait for us to open
knock knock
No, okay. I'll try grandma. You're not grandma. Whoa, you're in you're an iridescent. You've got my clothes on. Hello iridescent one
Gwap you want something? No, thank you. What about you?
Grandma made me these clothes pretty stylish. Yeah
Where's grandma? Are you grandma?
Oh, you're definitely grandma grandma. Hello grandma. Thank you
What does why do?
Hi granny. Oh my god. She has emi's pins in her hands
Hello grandma
Hello, dear little one. Do you have any electrical kit? I do for me
I'd love to make a poncho for you, but I need that cable
You'll never guess what I've got grandma. Here you go again. Oh, thank you my dear. I'll get to work right away
Okay, okay. Go. Hey. Hey get it grandma. Get it. Hey
The message was written in circuit schematics. I think the y prompt on the door was the knock oops
A new item game
There you go little one. It'll suit you well. Oh my god. Can I put it on? How'd I put it on?
Uh inventory up
Poncho show to be 12. Oh, can I not put it on?
It looks really warm. Perfect for a cold robot
Cold robot of this
Hi
Any cold is this where I came from? I think this is where I came from
Yeah, it is uh a cold robot right. Let's look for a niki-biki
Uh cold robot cold robot
Oh my god more fizzy juice speaking of fizzy juice hydration check
Okay, here we go downloading you wouldn't download an energy drink remember
Oh, it's just rip humans
Okay, well that answer that question then
RIP humans. Okay humans were the first residents around here. It seems that they're all passed away
What do you think it feels like being dead? I know it's silly coming from me
But are they actually at peace? Well, I'd be at peace when I die. I don't know what death feels like for an AI
I'm sorry. I don't want to break the myth. Let's go. No, you're allowed to inquire about things
What are you on about?
You know what you're allowed to ask questions. Hi buddy. Do you need a jacket?
Hello, no, you don't want to talk to me
I guess not
Do you need a jacket? No, you're the shopkeeper. That's region. I don't think a jacket would make me feel better
Who needs a jacket?
Hi, are you still mad?
Okay, you believe it man
Stop playing over my shop. You rest galleons the rip humans is because of the title and we're strong you won
Do you need a jacket? You don't have one
Hmm
Do you need a jacket jacket?
I need don't need jacket. Hmm
Oh wait, you're right. I can't interact with the store
Oh no
Please don't act like a child. I'm not gonna hurt you
Hey
Is that supposed to hear that?
Huh
Uh
I don't know who needs a jacket. Have I then need to go up? Maybe there's someone on the roof that needs a jacket
Is there a monk that's missing a jacket? No, you guys are all
Jacketed up
Oh you you you don't have a jacket here buddy
To help us prevent the slums has its threats and preparation is key. Okay
Can I give you this?
Hmm
Do you guys don't want a jacket? I'm guessing you don't want one either. Look at the hidden gems in the trash pennies from heaven or somewhere anyway
Okay
So don't want either
Ah draft. Okay. Okay
Someone wants me moz jacket, but I
I'll scan the floor. I've not spoken with you. Have I
Do you need a new jacket? I take care of the plants the humans improve them so much now
They require very little like I just had a bit of water and look how they get really amazing tech
Check the programmer guy. Where was that same?
Uh
Programmer was down this way too
No, hold on wait, I was down here wasn't it?
Hey, okay knock knock let me in let me in
No, that guy's standing right here so
Hi, okay. Thanks for letting me in. I appreciate it
It's just it's just like what?
Oh my god, new song new song. Right. Well. Oh, no, you closed the door draft. Um
Hi
You just the door guy
You're here for ellie. It's just over there. Uh ellie ellie. Give him an ellie ellie. Give him an ellie
Hi, buddy
You need jacket. Oh, you're freezing take this jacket right now
Yes, can I help you you most certainly can get yourself wrapped up or where'd you find it? It's amazing. Let me try it on
Yes, buddy all yours
Oh, you're first thing you
Oh, thank you. Oh, he's still shivering a bit, but he's getting warmer. Okay. Thank you for the poncho
Please come and see me if you need anything fix
I need anything
Oh
There's a clown coming out of the yo-yo
What is this information the tree is a scientific marvel
It's remarkable that human ingenuity
Found a way to create plants that thrive out sunlight organic life requires trees to purify to set you there
We both don't need it, but they take care of them anyway. It's what the humans would have wanted. Oh
Uh
Can I come right here? Hey, I want to go through this door. No, okay. He doesn't care. Um
So you'll fix something for us
Sorry, I just trashed in your house. Um, there was a fizzy just next to the lad. Okay, hold on
Uh
Oh, it was just oh it was just junk stuff
Uh, do you mean the lad upstairs?
Hey mom, it's dusk here and I might pass out. You you're allowed to fall asleep. I'm worried
God everyone likes caz up like the wee holiday destinations here translate
We were programmed to be slaves, but since
Many a year we have a soul hope one day the outsiders will find the exit of the town or more
I
Think all the sodas just come out of end of machines
Yeah
Let's say benzene on it benzene. Oh, that's right upstairs
Right. We have something that can repair stuff for us
Right. We'll go back to the music guy. I want back out. Please. Please. Let me outside
Thank you next door
Thank you very much. Um
Right, it looks like I need to go up now
Um
Maybe back to the pain guys. Maybe they've moved
Yeah, you don't say anything to me. Do you look like uh, yeah, that's okay
Okay, that's fine. Uh, right up up up. How'd I get up again?
Like literally anywhere, I guess
Let's have a go. This looks like that. Yeah, let's go
All the way the number of days ended up being
That's quite a while. Yeah, I'm not surprised
Uh, right
the youtuber throwing pain until I uh intervene sorry about that
Let's see what's up here
We've got a bucket from here
Huh
um
I need so the programmer can can I not go up here?
Game said no you can do as much else as you want but that's too far
Uh, right. What's over here?
Okay
Have I spoken to those guys? I don't think so. I don't want to take that in case it's like
Going the wrong way and have to climb all the way back up. Do you have another music sheet?
Oh, I don't know if I've got another song in me. Will we try it?
I definitely need to get up there, but how'd I get up there?
I don't know
Have I spoken to these two guys at the fire? I don't recall speaking to the guys at the fire
I thought there's a light here
I'm in someone's who's
The robot
The music just changed
Huh
I'm definitely in the right place
Have I heard the music changed any music changers?
Oh
Take a notebook. Sure. Um, that's theft but also
A strange notebook with a symbol on it. This one seems to belong to someone named climbing time
Everything is going according to plan. We've managed to
I can't read that fast
We managed to contact the upper level before the trans receiver went down. They are in a place called midtown
Apparently it's controlled by some kind of oppressive force. I talked to Momo earlier his eyes. I know his look
He will not come with us. I don't know what this means, but it'll probably be useful for there
We should go see the Momo person. I'm trying but I keep not walking into him
Okay, so there's like tons of
Okay, we've got two songs to go
Okay, we'll go speak to the musician
Uh, right how do I get down safely? How do I get down?
Let's go down
Gently easy easy. Right. Where's the music guy? Uh
Nope, this is the wrong way
Okay, I'm just gonna sing secret tunnel for one of them. It doesn't even count
Two kittens
Forbidden from one another
Their parents debate their people
Yes, I'm fine more. You'll never guess what I have on my person. Okay, we have three. Okay, let's do three
Untitled the tune contains 44 notes
You're gonna need to let them cook on that one ask them to do Wonderwall
I'm not sure I can do this one. This one's probably the closest one to me not gonna lie
Uh
Oh, thank you for the music practice. Yeah. Yeah. I've got one more
Cool down. Okay. Okay. Okay. Cool down. We've got a prompt
It's a hot
It's a hot summer day and a feeling okay
And the air is going through my hair and killing me then and it feels real nice to be
Our cat in town. Oh, I feel so good
And it feels so nice and the sun is shining and feels alive and I'm going
And it's going great because I'm a cool cat on a hot summer day
Oh
He's gone. Oh, he's gone. Hey. Hey fuck him up. Hey. Hey. Hey fuck him up. Hey
Hey
We did it uncle
Okay, we did it right now we should actually probably progress the mission now
um
In the moment give him an animal right go. Sorry go to this freaking guy. Sorry. He's up right. Let's go upstairs
Because I keep I have no idea where I'm actually going
I love this goofy siren. Like just because you can't sing doesn't mean shouldn't you know what I'm saying?
Right again pink guys
Um
Uh, right I'm just checking. Oh wait
Wait the elevator doesn't work, but that's where I'm supposed to go. Huh
Yeah
Right I went into that hidden room
There's a bucket and I'm up
Why do you have to rune horse in moments and I'm gonna give him an animal because it's my earworm. I've got it stuck in my head
Why or how?
Okay, let's go this let's go dead ahead this time
And that chair was spinning on an axis I go dead ahead. Can I like do a wraparound?
Maybe
Don't ray him off now. Oh, hello
Oh, are you an elderly robot? Hi old man
Oh, hey, it's you you do look weird and small, but there's something about your old chap
I feel compelled to pet you, but I won't because I don't understand why
Oh, yeah, you want to pet me? I'm uh, oh, I can't pet. I can't get a pet. Okay. You can pet me in another way
Oh, there's a vending machine
I ran you in make it better
Hello
Bonk
That's right. I'm I'm taping in the court that one. We got so juice
Okay, we get an energy drink. I guess the robots can have energy drink
Okay
Oh, it is TV bonk. I press the big button
You know, maybe sometimes TV sometimes or maybe she sometimes or maybe good
News channel
Uh, are you going to need nature documentaries?
Oh my god, the robot's really straight up doing TV. That's horrible
Oh, I see it. I see it. I see
Please tell me I finally did it
Is this where I'm supposed to go?
I know it's playing the mysterious music again. I'm just getting that freaking document or something
Translate
Hey doc, I found the keys to the safe. You need to be more careful with these
It's not enough to bury the safe behind a bunch of books the librarian. Okay. Well, we have our heading
behind books
There's a lot of books
This is a lot
There's too many books in here
I was like properly in the library. So is there something I can interact with?
Stealing time it's not stealing I see I see I see and give him a snowbreak. Oh, no
It's there is how to develop your artificial intelligence in order to be creative as a real human volume
I see rain. Hi, I see
And um, uh, uh, sorry music time. He don't mind for no
Oh
Everybody wants to be a cat because the cat's the only cat that knows
Hi snowberries. What were you up to you hooligans today?
There'll be no more landing a train
A I can't figure out where the safe is unfortunately
Did you guys like aces news short? Yeah. Oh, I found it. Uh, this one, please
What is it take
The strange notebook with the symbol on it you're watching cartoons. Oh, that's so good
I actually have aces
Short linked if you want to literally listen to her laughing in the background like a maniac
Uh, it's a strange notebook with a symbol on it. This one seems to belong to someone named the dog
After weeks of research I've confined a spectrum
Spectrometer with a powerful UV lamp with this it should be capable of warding the off dessert
The initial attempt was explosive. I might have to test on the real conditions
I don't know what this means, but I'll probably be useful later
We should go see that momo person who guardian tool. I'm trying. I keep going everywhere but him
I don't know where he is
please
The ac weas classic on his blue
Right, so I got a thing from being in here. So how do I get out again?
Oh, okay
There's something on the shelf there
What is that?
What's on the shelf over here?
I see it
Why?
Oh, I can go for a cat nap. Oh, why not nice warm library
Soft kitty warm kitty little ball of fur
Happy kitty sleepy kitty purr purr purr
Okay, we have had a cat nap
We are now going to try and get to this momo person. We've been at it for a wee hot setting now
Uh, unfortunately following the light is not working for this. Um
I think I just need to get higher up to like more obscure places
I guess right. I've done that vending machine. Can I jump across? I can
Can it looks like I should be able to jump up though. Are you sure?
No, I can
I think I think I'm gonna need a
I want to say I need help, but I don't even know if you can explain where I need to go
Because there's just so much
I've been there I've been there have I been on top of that yet? I don't know. I don't think I have
I'm just trying to go anywhere. I've not been
Another ASMR she had 9,000. Oh god my desk like just that's so bright
It does look like I can go this way. Hold on
Excuse me. Pardon me. Come to me. Right. So I've been in that window
Which is fine
No, if I can go like oh, there's
Oh, yeah ready for an uncle
Suffering from success actually at um though
Uh, I've got two more collabs to write. Oh, this is not going well. Um, I've got two. Is this just a scratch?
Let me in please let me in. I don't know where to go
What's that sound at the door? It's probably nothing
I assure you it's not nothing come at the door right now open this door
Show me who I'm supposed to go to
Uh, right. Um, it's not like the music guy is gonna
Oh, we're going down. I'm yelling dimmer
Uh, yes, I have two more scripts to write and then all my ASMR collabs
I've got 11 with people outside of velour. I'm going normally
Um, and then I'm probably going to take a hot break on doing any clubs with anyone for a hot second
11 is a lot considering I've just came flying out the gate. Okay. We're ready for a prompt
Hey, I'm yeah, I'm definitely gonna focus on like meme ASMRs and solo stuff
After that for a bit. Thank you. I will practice music. Do you think you can find more? I absolutely can
You ready? I don't want it. Wait seven is a big number
two
Show item
Ballard of the lonely robot. I think I can play it. Okay. Okay a bit sad a bit sad. Okay
In senseless the best in the plane. I'm alone. I'm a robot and I'm in the rain and I'm sad
And I don't feel glad for what I'm feeling but then again all the humans are dead and I'm kind of sad
And I'm not so glad
Hit him with a rover
Okay, okay, that wasn't that wasn't hopefully the next one's a bit more upbeat. Okay
Uh, we've got one more for you buddy one more mildly important information
Okay
Other heroes here
I have something I want to share and tell you it's something that I think you should care about
It's an information overload in this world of
Overgrown and everything inside is so looking. Okay. That was a really short one to try and come up with anything
Thank you. Mr. Musician
Um, unfortunately, I think I'm stuck right now. Um
Kind of sounds like music from Omori
Can you lay in the pillows? I think so. I think it's just a napspot
I'm trying to freaking
You freaking freaks. I don't know how to progress
I don't know. Maybe I need to
Do I have enough energy drinks for the merchant? Hold on. How many energy drinks?
One two, right, so I don't have enough for whatever the merchants hiding so maybe that's what I need to get access to normal
I don't know
Uh
How'd it go? No, that's down close enough. I was one way or another honestly. You're doing great. Keep it up
Sweet. Oh, and we're going down again. Okay. It's fine. It's fine. I didn't need to go. Okay. It's fine. I didn't need to go up
uh
I like writing songs in my spare time. So I'm come up. I'm jealous you can come up with lyrics on the spot
I'm just going for it. Literally. It gives me a prompt. I'm not even rhyming properly. You're just being nice to me
Actually, I'm not even rhyming and I'm just like
That's me. Right. Okay. So that's me more right. How'd I get up?
I was kind of coming down from here. I've already been this way, right?
Sorry, it's probably have I been in here? Uh, this is the top of the bar
Oh, these are the two that I've never speak to
Hello
I left it in the streets and the next day the zarks consumed it. That's crazy. They can eat everything
Hello, can I rub against your legs?
I'm a male in your little heart
Yeah, that's great. You love the pooters. What's this?
Oh, is this where we're supposed to go if I actually progress the story line properly?
I
Shawnee trying not to fumble too hard. It's called improv. Shawnee. It's called improv. Oh, yeah
You like the way that I don't rhyme because I don't have enough time to prepare for what I'm going to say next. I don't
Right. I've already been in there. You can't fill me
Fill me once shame on you. Fill me twice shame on you. Is anyone played straight? Am I supposed to get the third thing now?
Despite what Shawnee says, she's actually a good thing, right?
I really don't
Wait, I'm an idiot. No
Pull the other way
I'm an idiot and it's been there the whole time. Am I going crazy?
Wait, no, have I been here? Am I good?
It's been here the whole time
Oh, okay, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's been here the whole time
Improv I
Oh
My god, actual gamer moment. It's been here the entire time and I've been
Well, you know what? I wouldn't be singing them songs if I was streamlined and okay translate
outsiders
Forbidden from one another
Um me
It's never going to wait
Why did I let them go? I'm all alone now. Hey, what do you want?
Uh, I want
To leave
This is a picture of outside. Do you want to go there meow? Well, don't bother waste the time
I'll bring you only the loneliness and despair my friends had that dream too, but now they're gone and I'm all alone
I don't know where they ended up. I tried to contact but that receiver doesn't work
My friends and I took her notes of her research about the outside here. Take mine if you really want to go there
Okay
You're on your own. I'm done with the outside. Well, wait, that's it
Momo seems very sad. He misses his friends. Let's check the notebook
The outsider manifesto. We must go outside at any cost. We must protect our brothers and sisters
We must stay away from dessert. It is saying clementime zanzibar doc and momo
That does not say zanzibar. Does it what the fuck does that say zit belt?
his are
The belt is our okay zanzibar. Honestly, isn't that bad? I'm not even going to be mad at myself
I don't like honestly, I think we should find the other notebooks. Okay, right. That's fine
Did it say a password or did it curse? We'll never know right
Hey, little cat. You're still looking for useless books, right? If I got if I got everyone's book by accident
Oh, hold on. We're streamlined. Sorry me mucking about. I actually just streamlined this. Okay. Oh, you found clementime snows
She was really brave. You know the most fearless person I ever met
Hey cat, you're still looking for the notes. No, yeah now you oh it belonged to doc
He was really a huge nerd for electronic stuff. He was was always on the verge of great discovery
No way I streamlined this. I've got all of them feels good man. That's my notebook. I was oh
Who that need
Zanzibar freaking thing. Zanzibar. Isn't that a song from
Jack Black or something?
Back home to a movie. Oh, there's a coup
Oh back home to I remember this video game it was made just after I was created. I think I can't remember it
Well the scientist and I spent a lot of time playing it. It was fun. I miss him. I can't even remember his name
You'll remember soon enough. Don't force it
And I know it's frustrating if you don't know things off the top of your head, but
What the what kind of poster is that?
Problem. Is this like troll face their version of troll face?
Ooh rack in size and one problem. No
What a bizarre little
Thank you
Uh
What lunch
Oh
I got a achievement called curiosity killed cat. Oh, no. I'm not walking in the right direction. I'm like all spun around
Stop spinning
You're gonna make mercy sick
It's just good terrible more stop. Wait. I can't get it all. Oh
Okay, that's what that's what I thought exactly
Uh, what do you do?
You
Don't do much, but that's okay. You don't have to do much translate
The city has a cylindrical shape of 450 in diameter
There is a level above ours the ceiling the city has
Seems to have a ceiling if I remember my books the big blue skies hidden behind it curious
Um, what's up here anything for me? I don't know where the last no
There's them
Right, I will come back with your stinky notepad
And as evidence that I have been here take this
You deserve it for not for hiding in plain sight from me. Okay
The symbol on the wall watches one what symbol
Okay, okay, so he's gonna point out
What one haven't I been to
I've been in that one. I've been in that one. So it's this one over here
How'd I get there
Okay getting that first
Yeah, I haven't been in that one
Sorry didn't mean to break it
Have I been in that one?
Oh no, I'm gonna have to use my head right okay go across
Zanzibar was a player we player map in helo. Oh, maybe
Challenge play the game with a bag on your head. That's not even possible the controls don't respond
Right if there's a symbol over here, did I go in this one or not? I think I took the ledge down. Yeah
Translate ventilation power supply
I need to break it
Okay, oh my god, we did it I get it
Okay, big jump be brave. Oh, you're fine. That's just a we drop. Sorry to scare you like that, buddy
Oh
Just that just a little bit of myth normally you're not really supposed to leave much of a trace behind but he will press y
Let me out
Okay, so we have a shortcut. Okay, but we need to
But
Hello, hello, hello, any oh, we got some fresh water
Speaking of water, I'm actually gonna open my bottle. Oh, no, I have a bottle of water from yesterday that is
Stop drinking we don't want you to pee everywhere
Chat we need to band together to mass spam bad cat puns. No
Shawna got me feeling something kind of way. Yeah, I like the necklace
Uh, right, there's there must be a book in here. Sorry. Wait. Whoa. What was that?
Wait, it's on top of the thing
Finally the last notebook this one seems to belong to Zanzaba
All traces of organic life has disappeared except for what we call deserves
They seem to eat almost anything that moves and breed at an inconceivable rate get it because they can see fast
Uh, it's it's as if being walked in the city wasn't hard enough. Oh
There's also a lot in this book. I said I found a design flaw in the transceiver
But I think I figured out how to fix it. Here's the equation with this. We should be able to help
Momo repair the transfer if it can communicate with the upper levels that could be our way up
Let's show him what fun. Okay, baby
Oh, there's a thing down there to remember. I see it. How'd I get there? Can I get done? I would like to remember
Member in the memory
What's this? C14
Remarkable companions have evolved so much in the early days
They're simple ai merely in
Imitated human art now. This is all on their own humans often said that making art is important in desperate situations
These are certainly desperate times
Getting his memories back
Uh, actually should I come back up again? I think so. Whoops. Oh, and I'm going further down. Oh, and I'm going further down still
Okay, let's just uh
Let's just climb up a different location. Sometimes it's a bit finicky
Right, I need to go top right
I've made an
I have made an incredible decision. We shall band together for now. We are Legion and meow
Or or is night from
What are you saying?
Why are you blue?
I have probably gone the longest way possible to get back to this guy. Sorry
Unfortunately
I don't wrong. Sorry. Sorry. It was a big jump. I shouldn't have done that to you. Oh, we need to go up
We're getting there
It's just taking me a hot second because I'm a little slow in the head
But I thank you for being patient for me reeflings
Okay, let's get up up ease. Hello. I did it. I got your quest items
Are you still looking for the notebook? Yes, that's all
That's his notebook, right? I never quite understood what he was talking about most of the time
But he was very wise. Wait, you actually found all my friends notebook
Oh, what's that? No, the transfer you were can be repaired. That's incredible. That means we should be able to communicate outside of the slum
Climbing time
Hey Johnny. Hi chat. Hi, Broly legend. Thank you for the tip
and
Climbing time doc. I'm sorry. I doubted our cause. I promise you'll find a way to reach the servers
Thank you. We might be able to find you a way up now. Let's fix this piece of junk trans receiver
The tv
Or diameter
Oh wait our friend in the programming thing said he'll fix anything. Oh, wait, he just did it come with me
Come with me
Up there see that building high above others
Yeah
If you install the transceiver at the very top of that tower, you should be able to communicate to go to the city
My friends might still be out there. If there's any way out, they'll know
There's only one small click enough to evade the zarks. We need you a little outsider. Bring us to the sky
That's kind of that lane kind of goes hard
Oh no, I need to get ready to run I think
Oh no
I don't like it already
When do they start jumping out at me? How much time do I have?
Oh no, oh no, this can't be right, okay
I can't even see where to go
I
Assume I just jump up from over there. I don't want them to grab me but we're gonna
That they're trying to get their attention
Okay
Uh, uh, uh, can I just hold a and you go up? Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Perfect
Okay, keep her going eggs bacon grits sausage
Got a flat ass, but it still takes sausage
Oh no
Oh no, oh get me up. Just get me up. Oh my god. Oh no
Oh my god, okay. Okay. What's the summer memory? Sorry. Are they chasing me?
Oh
I've got nine lines check. Yeah, the city is full of neon. It wasn't all this way
We used to be strict energy caps, especially in the slums, but people couldn't handle the concept dodging
One day someone lit up rainbow lamps neon signs all over the house that person was taken away and never seen the game
Again, but people saw hope and not long after everyone started putting lots of lights in their homes
There was nothing their pressers could do
It was the way for people to see colors again like on the outside. I think it helped
Okay, we're there progress. I don't want to go back down. Please don't make me go back down there
Is this not the way should we do we?
Oh, no, it's up. I see it
Oh, we have a little swing
Swing again on it. Oh, okay. Okay. We have swing mechanics stuff
Uh
Barrel classic rollover. Okay
But not roll off the map. Oh, no
That's why there's that metal pole there
Why is it so cold?
I knew it's drawn in with the fire. Eh, I'm playing as a cat. Okay
Is there more of those bogey things ahead? Okay, I'm holding the right trigger. So we were running
Where
Ah, oh no, there's like there's a mechanic up ahead. What is it?
What is it?
What's the mechanic? I see red. I see a code
I see it looks like I can just jump up to the left and I'll honestly
Hack the door
I'm waiting till they all come over
Wait, I can't lock them in though. Wait, do I need to lock them in?
I'm not very bright. Wait
I'm not very bright. Is that them all?
Oh
What and then go okay, okay, okay
Okay, I get it. I get it
Okay, and they can't jump over. Okay. I get it. I get it. I understand that was
You want to go any faster buddy? Jeez. Not like there's like
Organisms are ready. They mull your eyeballs out the socket
Yeah
I'll go on achievement for jumping 500 times and it's called catapult
Okay, we did it. Oh, no, there's more. Whoa
Good thing this game has aim assist
Uh
Are they gonna like pop out here? Oh, no
Oh, please get me up. Oh, no. Oh, yes, and then move the plank darlin my my yin-yur
Okay
Oh
Oh, not good not good not good not good not good
Okay, where do we need to go?
I see a light to the right. So maybe jump on that scaffolding and then they're stuck through here
Okay, I'm gonna my money's on the scaffolding to the right
Okay, let's go. Send it. Send it buddy. Send it. Send it. Send it. Send it
What is there more
Oh, I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like it
Oh, I don't like being chased. Please no more
Okay, what's going on here?
Did I just see some behind me? Okay. Why did I want to hack the door?
Am I being chased? No, right. They're stuck inside
There's a barrel. Okay barrels
Hold on. Right. Okay. We can discover this memory first
Okay, Neco Neco
Neco corporate they were reason for waste management as trash from the upper levels overloaded
They tried to develop a bacteria to dissolve at all after the humans disappeared that bacteria mutated growing eaten away more than trash
And now we have drugs. Let's go
Of course, it's a corporation that caused the d- mmm. I'm not surprised. This is my kind of game. That's right preach preach
Right, so
Hold on I'm just trying to
So what open that gate they'll chase me and then grab the barrel very quickly
And roll it over
Okay, hold on hold on
Okay, let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Meow. Come on chase me chase me
Me acting all brave because I'm like, yeah, I know what the plan is also me absolutely shitting myself
Please a bit faster
Oh, wait, can I hack myself in here?
No, no, no, wait. I messed up
Bring
Dang. Oh, no, it's fine
They can't come for me because they're stuck at that wall
Oh, sorry, I heard something. Oh my god. Sorry. They made a really weird noise there and that freaked me out
Oh
What do you mean? I should play horror games. What are you talking about?
No, they fucking terrify me
Terrify like literally horror games or like donut on stuff because it just
Horrifies me so much
Okay, oh, yeah, you like that I face it maneuvers
Up up up. Oh, that wasn't much of an up, but I'll take it. Oh, okay. That wasn't up. We're fine. We're safe. Whoa. You climb up that jeez
Verically, are we safe over there?
I see a lever
I see a lift
I think I see bodies. I see little glowing things
Well
I was fine just a layer at the mold where I'm going
I was kind of kidding
I was kind of kidding. I think I need to stall out the lift coming down
Come on
There's more dropping. Wait, that's cheating
They're gonna stop me from running around. Oh wait, there is I see the lift. I see the lift
It's coming down the shaft. I am
Why is there so many jump jump?
Please please get saved. Oh my god. Go. Oh my god. We just beat their vertical leap
Oh, that's awful. That is awful. Please tell me we can unlock a gun. I'm not even kidding. Please tell me we get a gun
Oh
We need the mealmen we need the movement the mealmen
I
I really hope this cat gets a gun. I'm so sorry. There's no gun. No, I have to run away the entire time
That's terrifying
I'm so stressed
Are we safe?
Right
Right open
I demand you open how'd I get up? I go like this
First of all
Okay, there's no orange around. I think I'm safe
Here is put the transceiver on the antenna this
Uh transceiver here you go
Oh
We did it
We're lighting it up. What does it mean? I don't really know. Well, we're communicating with the higher city, I guess
Hydration check little reefling
I love the aesthetics of this game. Yeah
Activate in the elevator. Oh, maybe
Look the view is beautiful from here. I remember now the city it was meant to be a shelter. Oh
No
Looks like those look like stars, but they're only light markings
Lights marking the hermetic
Roof sealing off the city
Mankind built the shelter to protect themselves from the outside
But I came at a cost nobody can get out
The outside was a disaster completely barren unlivable and dangerous
But if you come from there, it must mean it's safe again
And my promise wasn't just to go to the outside. It was to open the city
Yeah, is that your goal
I still don't understand why some memories are coming back and others aren't but I'm certain now. This is my purpose
I have to open the city. Come on. Let's get back and find Momo now that we've connected the transmitter
We should be able to get help
Okay, okay
Not bad
This is the longest ride we're putting a lot of faith in this little cat in a bucket honestly
Cola burp emote win
Soon everyone's emotes got submitted before me
Mercy has been accepted as errors. I'm waiting to be accepted and then mine are being done last because um
I
Want the girls stuff to be done first and reeflings you guys are actually like super understanding the slums part two
No, get me out of the slums. Come on. I've been here a little too long
Oh my god, I bought these for Gimli and Vigo and
Vigo doesn't play with toys and Gimli only plays with a specific toy that they discontinued and I'm absolutely reading
Oh, no, he went
Little outsider if you're all that's such a cute nickname
Little outsider if you're reading this that means you're still alive. Excellent
I took some equipment to the bar to take advantage of their antenna. Come meet me there
I've locked the window, but the code to open it is simple. It is
Be careful it's case sensitive. See at the bar that must be the code for the window near the entrance looks cool
Okay, the bar we know where the bar is
Oh this
Oh
Okay, that was I thought amen
The code at the bar. Sorry. I get it now. Okay. Uh, let me
refresh my memory of the city really quickly
Uh, I can't remember where the bar is, but you know what we'll just make our way down
And hope we're going the right way
Uh, is that the bar? Oh, maybe no, no down little little outsider or or yinya as I call you please go down
Yeah, just like that. Yay. This is it
Hi momo
Hey little furball
Come here. I managed to get a signal. All right. Let's go buddy. Show me what you're working with. Oh, sorry
We've got a little too excited
But you show it. Oh, I'll pull up a chair. Well, I'll hold on let me get up
Hold on. Let me get up. Oh, he actually putt me off. Oh, I'm getting head cut
Let me see if I can get this thing working
Hi, mommy. This cat ears look cute. Yeah, I'm a necklace today. Oh, I've almost got it
Hello, can anyone hear me?
Hello, yes, we can hear you. We're from the slums. We're looking for a way out and wait, is that you zanzibar?
Momo
I can't believe it. I'm so happy to hear your voice zanzibar. Where are you? Are the others okay? Yes
We are safe. We found a way up
Up
Hello, do you still hear me? You have to go through the sewers to reach us. It's very dangerous
It's not because everywhere
Sewers, how? Hello
Darn it. We've lost the signal
I can't believe it. Zanzibar is alive. He and the other outsiders managed to go up through the sewers
The sewers are the most dangerous place in the slums, but if zanzibar made it there must be a way
You'll never get past the sewers. It's infested with zirks. They'll make a quick meal out of you
Especially you little one
Many tried their luck in the past and it does the end well
Anyway, I warned you. Your business is none of my business
Oh, he he gave him a warning
Mmm
Sumis his father doc used to be a great scientist who was working on some new weapon to fight the zirks
A few years ago. He went off to test the device. I love a cave back
Seamuses never in the south
up here
Not so good
Don't listen to seamus. He's just scared like I was a doc bill weapon
That's our ticket to join the outsiders
In his notebook doc mentioned a secret lab a few times that must be where he was working on it
There might be a clue in Seamuses apartment. Come on. Follow me
I'll follow you
I will follow you
Follow you wherever you
mainly
Because I'm just a kitty cat
Down in the slums without my little family
Of shot no are in is it two tail two dots
Two dots on tail. I've forgotten in the other cat. Oh, he's still cleaning it off
Bro, I think you're gonna have to get a mural down or something because uh, yeah, but you ain't cleaning up paint on concrete
Oh, is this a uh, no point in translating. I thought it was a memory. Oh knock knock
Let us in
Two dots poke a dot. Oh, that sounds right. Come on. Seamus open the door. You know, your father would have wanted to help us
Two dots poke a dot shot noir and Cali Cali Cali Caloo
Well, that was to be expected the situation is pretty tough on Seamus. He doesn't want to hear about the outsiders
He won't help me, but you I think I have an idea
Okay, what's your idea Momo?
Oh, I'm to go in are you sure here take doc's notebook and show it to Seamus
It contains a lot of information that will hopefully act as an electoral shock
Find the secret lab little outsider. Oh, that's such a cute name
I'm going back to the bar to try and re-establish communication with others. Okay. Thank you Momo
Hi Seamus
I scared him
No, no, don't shoot me away take this. What is it? Wait, this is my papa
Oh, wow, I never knew there's a secret room here in our flat, but where?
Uh, okay. Well considering there's loads of things to knock down on the wall. I'm a gobo knock all the things off the wall
They really didn't hide it did they? Okay, but what's the code? I don't see any numbers and stuff. These schematics
I
Like how to jump back every time
Oh, there's like little
What is this thing translate?
Time will tell
You will considering the humans are all parish. Yeah, time will tell actually
Actually factually as you are correct. Is it better than little seaweed? No, you don't call me little outsider
I say being all we foreigner. I'm like, oh, why are you calling me we foreigner the fuck?
That's your clue time will tell
Oh
The clocks. Okay the clocks. Okay. What time?
Two o'clock five o'clock one o'clock one o'clock two five one one
Two five one one. Yeah. Okay. Time will tell. Yeah. Time really did tell
Oh, I missed the animation of the door opening up. Sorry. Sorry. I didn't realize it was gonna be right there
Hello
Wow
Oh, there's bugs inside
I've never seen this room. I can't believe he managed to hide it from me all this time
These blueprints. They must be for dessert weapon. Wait, you said I didn't get a gun
Papa was always so secretive with his work. He told me the weapon was working in theory
But I needed a real life test. He went outside the slums and he never came back
That must be very sweet
The bugs
Translate
Observations cute sound, but never friendly old bacteria of human time eat all kinds of materials total
Vision in the darkness reacts to intense light and that's a different color
Um
It's just a shelf. So wait, what am I to do? I'm just a cat the fuck
What you want me to do here knock some stuff over
Don't tell me this one it's got the light next to it. That's when you know
What wait one match is supposed to do though
Translate
Uh robot news headlines lurks are officially no longer under control. They now eat metal. Okay
Wait, oh, sorry. That was a bit too much of a jump. Was it in the box?
I don't know what I'm supposed to do. Sorry talk
Find anything interesting in here. Okay, find something
Oh, I was like, um under the table
Uh power socket. I already read that
Uh, what's this box up here?
I
Okay, yeah, there we go
Take broken track broken the guy can fix it the programmer
Hello
Hydration check refling find anything interesting in here. Uh, yes this
Hmm
Wait, I remember that that's his tracker
Papa always used that tracker to keep an eye on where I was
Maybe we can reverse it to find where he went. I can't believe my papa might still be alive
I've missed him so much. You need a weapon for the zirks, right? My papa definitely took one with him
We just need to repair the tracker so we can find him someone in the slum should be able to help come with me
I'll open the door for you. Okay
Yes, we already know because we did the guy of favor
Um, it's a big uv torch. Oh, it's not actually like a pew pew
You get a flashlight
You mean a torch? That's right. I'm britishifying you right now. Thank you
Thank you. Um, right
Programmer
Thank you for the tip miss morgan good kitty
Soft kitty warm kitty little ball of fur
Meet I've not met you yet. Hello. Look at all of this great stuff that falls into our trash. So many treasures
Should go visit the barman. Yeah
Um
Where was the programmer?
Pet gimley and let him pour purr into your 3d. Oh
Gimley's a girl
I'm sorry to do that to you. Gimley's a wee girl
Please let me in me. I'm yummy. I'm yummy. I'm yummy. I'm yummy. I'm yummy in
The music man, I don't have any more music
I'm out of music
I don't have any
I know it's I know calling a girl cat gimley is misleading but
She has a tiny bit of ginger on her
So I called her gimley
And then I can go that's my wee lad gimbals
thanks for the poncho please see me if you'll never need something fixed you'll
never guess what I got oh you're still shivering oh you're perusing you show
item oh wow that's a great tracker I recognize it's the tohima BR2000 you
can track anyone with this little gadget may I please be my guest let me take a
look just gotta give it an update and one more thing voila there you go that
one good luck finding who you're looking for thank you I think we found all
bar one of the music sheet is there a special thing oh sleepy nest or more
like siesta cuz he takes loads of naps get it cuz siesta means to take a nap
like an afternoon nap so I'm sorry thank you um now I go to the bar cuz I've
got a tracker did you get anywhere buddy Momo I'm really struggling to get the
connection back did you find anything interesting I found a tracker what's that
thing oh I'm not to show you sorry uh Seamus oh dear I don't know where he is
is he to the right no he's done here
yeah somewhere past the thing okay here Seamus hi guess what I got a I
absolutely did it's all yours you did it you fixed it well done get on give it
here all yours
so you need to apologize for that one like half of the ones I made during the
pun revolution approval the audience words and laughter oh my sights are an
or a star you just haven't my terrible job yeah I also think people would do a
better job we got a pain it's Papa alive I can't believe it let's follow the
tracker maybe we'll find where my papa went okay buddy I trust you let's go
very slowly now
what do we think history so far have you guys the clocks are based 16 and not
what does that mean this is a cute game I have to admit I got a bit turned around
trying to get to that guy but now that we did it and we pretty much did all the
other stuff it's a perfect game I just want my gun so I don't have to run away
like a maniac every time I see this a zur 16 hours in a day it's interesting to
see how differently you're playing from a zur what's a zur that must be it he
really left the slum yeah it's dangerous out there but I must be sure I need to
know let's do this as the coconut one said in Elden Ring let's get to it
the earth rotational periods go down ours just as they work better with hexadecimal
or maybe the capital is pigs one and the work day got changed to 16 oh no
oh it's pulsating the only thing throw but I want in the vicinity near me is a
tentacle can I be attacked here no he's shown me where go wait if he's shown me
where it goes or a secret or something yeah this isn't really like much of a
secret place I'm a just following and not muck about as Zora chose war picked a
gun and killed everyone look all these eggs they will eat us I can't do this
I'm not as fast as you the Zorks will get me for sure here take this badge my
papa will recognize that he will know that you're a friend gained a new I am
whoa I'll open the door for you oh god this is gonna be a running sequence I
just know you thank you for your help see miss you were a great help bye bye
buddy I can't we give you a little rig leg rub okay I don't see orange yeah when
us that's very bright oh there's a memory to the left okay I think I'm safe a
little bit I don't see the orange yeah okay it's fine it's fine relax don't have
it it's not a horror game strongy relax we loved it undulating flesh walls I
never noticed a really cool detail look at how huge this wall is oh yes I remember
it was a symbol of the division between those in the slums and in midtown that
and the fact that they kept throwing their garbage down here what horrible thing
to do maybe that's why they failed good I love this game already yes take down
the high table I understand strongy good refling good refling you pleased me
you will be rewarded for such loyalty this dad just run right down the middle
I'm trying to look ahead it doesn't look like I go up it looks like I go down and
run okay okay let's go let's just run send it little putters I'm holding a I
repeat I am holding a oh get up get up oh get on up get on up get on up they are
flinging chat they are flinging I am getting scared I am getting scared but
it's okay I'm cat I'm a kitty cat and I run run run run and I run run run cat
I'm a kitty cat and I run run run run run run cat
And I run run run run run run run run run run this is a dead end
Underneath underneath underneath underneath underneath underneath
Whoa why am I stuck why mistock okay, it's fine. I'm not stuck
This way and swing it back
Swing it back now y'all
Chris grows
And then go back and then swing it one more time
Give me the old wrap around
Could see it I could see where the under passage was cuz they lit it up
I have to admit the game design with lighting up where you're supposed to go next. I appreciate greatly
Is that trolley
That's quite a lot to dodge
Hey
Do the Hawaiian search like oh my god, hold on little buddy. Oh
Oh ouch, are you okay in your
That was a huge fall it was dog should be nearby we must be cool. Are you okay? I'm limping
Can dog patches up? Are we gonna be okay? Oh
No, how'd uh oh you okay? Oh, we're walking off. Okay. We're walking off
Okay, give it like yeah, you're you're you're spit has healing properties. Okay. I guess we have to go up I
Can hear something is it just frogs like ambience or is like is it something that's gonna there's nothing orange though
The video game wouldn't be so cruel as to not show orange if there's enemies nearby surely the game wouldn't do that
No, those are frogs
I'm actually a really good fool
Same leg it's never fully healed per thing. Oh
No
Where they need to go
Hold on
Hold on I'm about to cross a barrier where they need to go. I can't see
Just jump across the bridge and then to the right cuz it's all lit up there
Oh you turn hold on this is lit up. Oh
Use item
An energy drink. Well, it's definitely no way hmm. It's an electrical generator, but it seems to require some other part function. Okay
Okay, we're not gonna get jumped on this side, I don't think because of that generator we need to come back to it
Did we follow the cable? I think so
Okay, when the music gets intense I'll start screaming
I
Really don't want to make noise. Oh
Thank goodness it's in a cage, why is it in a cage because that baits clearly
What generate? Uh
Hello
Is this on its head? Oh, hello
Oh
Sorry, didn't mean to scare of course the scientist has like crazy cables coming over this here
Wow
Wait, you're not a zerk. Who are you? That's my badge you're wearing. How'd you find it?
Did my son send you? Oh, see miss you clever boy. You've been alone here for oh, I've been alone here for ages
I came here to test my defluxor, but it didn't go as planned. I wish I could go back home
I miss my son daily
You can have a look around the house if you want, but I have no idea how to escape this place
What do you what do you mean? Wait, you're not gonna say knows what to do remember
What do you remember little buddy? I've seen humans wear costumes like I mean similar
They were small and running around making lots of noise. Oh, they were children. Yes
The streets felt much more alive with children even with the difficulty they brought the adults seem to love them very much
Doc says he misses Seamus. Is this the same thing? Yeah, it is. Oh
No, no, he's out of beverages. Oh dear
What's going on here?
Hello radio. Oh
Why oh
I
Was this mean
But Morty you go to shove the mega seats. Oh, it does kind of oh, no
It does look a wee bit like Rick
Hey, be careful with the defluxor at fill charge it can explode zirks like
What do you mean be careful give give me it meow
This baby needs 1.21 gigawatts to work and the only thing around here that
Kind of just as a generator outside the house. The problem with that is it's not gonna start
I think a fuse blew and with all the zirks around it's too dangerous for me go and fix it
I'm not fast enough, but you might be if you reach the generator and replace the fuse
It should be able to get the defluxor recharge. Come on. Follow me. I'll show you what to do
Okay, I'm listening. Are you about to give me a weapon?
Do I need to not be absolutely terrified and shitting my panty loners? Hmm?
Cuz they just we ship my pants when it comes to these bad boys
Well, I was actually already at the generator, so I know where to go here take this fuse is brand new
Okay, thank you turning on the generator will be allowed to expect company once you fix the generator
It should be able to charge
The kick and kick start the defluxor you just need to follow this cable change the fuse and meet me back here
Best of luck. Okay, so there's gonna be a bit of a jump sequence once we start it, but that's fine. We know where to go
Surely they wouldn't spawn them in right now surely
Surely they wouldn't spawn them in right now. No, it's after I do the generator. Okay
The game is giving me a grace period. It's either I take a right or a left here
Okay, now what were they coming from I can do it
I can do it ominous red glow
Hey
Yes, give me that technology
Wait what I can't cross
Oh my god, bro, you're gonna need to aim bought this stuff. I can't get across cuz they're coming on the bridge
They need to wait until it involves the mall doc you need better aim I
Can't even get along the bridge
Think I'm okay, okay, you actually didn't do a bad job
Why would you do that game
You know that would scare me
This isn't a horror game. Why would you do that? Get me inside right now? Oh my god
Doc is beaming. Yeah, oh you celebrate is so happy hydration chair
Amazing you got the generator back on heck. Yeah, dude. You're well. Yeah
And how do you see you're welcome in French I've already forgotten
Doody and me duty and I
Yeah, my voice is unfortunately breaking at the moment
Have you seen how powerful the defluxer is it's definitely our way out here wait a minute
I might be able to mount this defluxer to your drone
Oh, that's exactly what I want to hear doc
Give me um, you know that guy that smashes like money on the table gif and basically that right now
You do not have to tell me twice. Oh
Oh, he popped
Thank you
It works the defluxer is now installed on your fancy drone
It's not meant to run off such a small amount of power if you use it too much a kid malfunction
Just remember it's dangerous. Now. Let's go back to the village. I'm coming home to my son. Oh
That's so adorable
You had I do press a
No, he's jumping on it. Wait, how do I use it?
Oh
Yeah, oh
My god, okay, it's a wee bit short. That's fine. It's better than nothing. I'ma take it. I must take it. Okay
Do you be bombs? Oh
Take out all those darks and we can get through yes
Wow, oh, sorry, I did it a bit quicker than the store. Well, it's working great
But as expected it can overheat let it cool for a bit when that happens
I hope we will last until we reach the village. Don't say that
Why don't you bring your freaking big-ass one as well? Why does it have to be down to me?
Like I'm a freaking cat. I'm literally in my head like oh
They're gonna start jumping out of those honestly. Oh
This is gonna make me so nervous
What's the dealio here
The switch doesn't work. I look like the electricity's been caught. I
See my barrels
Welcome to jump up on
Hold on let me think this
I don't really
No, not that
The pay there's not anything to jump
Reelings
The other barrel needs to go to the pay this play
It's the steam coming over
I see it. I couldn't see it before but I see it now. It wasn't the paper all it was the freaking vent
I know for a fact we're about to get jumped
I got an achievement from me I won one hundred we're about to get jumped sauce, but it's literally so obvious
Stop I'm scared. I don't know what way they're coming here and here
Stop the music was so intense. Oh
My god, we flinch sorry you need to like hack into my game right now so we can like group up on them
Is it just this group here
Okay, I think that was actually super fair and nice. Thank you
Oh
Please can we like upgrade the endurance or something? Oh
Please oh, please
Oh
Okay, that was close. Let's go back home
Yes, let's I'm blowing them up
I try to blow them up for the door. Sorry. I'm getting distracted. Let's go next
They seem to like you more than the dog
I think they go for organic matter like a preference if you will
Cuz I guess they killed all the humans. I
Hate when he walks like that. It means there's more coming
He's got murked by the zirks honestly
We've got to get jumped from behind or something I
Do not like this like I'm glad I've got a weapon, but I wish it wouldn't burn so quickly
My school first, no, oh we're here, right? Okay, we did it. Oh, he's gonna meet a son
Oh, they don't believe it. Oh
Oh
Oh, that's so sweet we got to do that. That was us reeflings. You're so nice. You've re-night knighted a father and son
I'm getting a pet from the Guardian
Thanks for saving Doc little friend. It's great to see that Seamus is no longer alone
Now we know what we we can fight back the zirks. Momo has been waiting for you by the sewers
Momo's been waiting for me by the sewers
Doc and Seamus look happy. I think we did a good thing together. Yeah, we did. Are you joking?
Look oh
Look look look. Oh, he's so happy look. They're physically connecting because they missed each other so much
And everyone's catching up with them
Me
Hi, Teddy. What's up? Oh Billy? You know my son Seamus. Oh
We'll let them catch up right as pointed this way to the sewer
They were catching up go go work. Thanks those dream take care take care
Please don't worry if you guys have to go and get stuff done. I'm very sorry. I couldn't find your last song
I'm so sorry. I don't know where your last piece was, but I enjoyed your music nonetheless friend
Hello
Momo is waiting for you on the boat. Okay, okay
Strony we still have time we can scour the streets. Do you know where the one I'm missing is?
If you pull up the names I can tell you which one we haven't submitted we submitted one called like
Unchai old find the last fizzy juice in the music. Oh dear
Where is the last fizzy juice?
Is it down an alley way that we haven't been down maybe?
Fizzy juice not in there
That's the way up
Oh, oh it's a shortcut. That's actually a pretty decent shortcut
Petite veils. Yes. I need that
Right, that's the bar
Is it on a rooftop we're only missing one yes, okay a
vending machine I
Feel like I've scoured the area for a vending machine. It's inside Momo's apartment. Oh
Yeah, that's a new unlock isn't it
Or I've gone too far maybe
That's that guy
Yeah, I'm getting a bit turned around hold on must be done this way
Okay
Hmm
Last song
Here these are just slept through the gap in the door with the bars in it
Slip through the gap the van. Oh, sorry, it's not even open
Slip through the gap in the door with the bars in it that Samus's apartment oops
Momo's apartment
Is that the one that was up
Must be because we were doing rooftop scale in in order to get any of those
Wow slip through the bars
Shut up to all my bars
Okay, give me a moment and we'll get the lesson
You're going down you silly goober I need to go up. Yeah like that. Yeah, perfect
That's not head all the way up to mom on top of the sun's when you go inside the bar doors in the side room
Was it this one, I mean there was only two apartments it can be it's either the window one or that one
I think it may be this one
It was a 50-50 because we know that dogs like Zanzibar one
The orange one not the library
No
Not the library
This wasn't Momo
Can't recall
This is
Maybe Momo's
Translate hey doc offensive
Jess a librarian. Okay. No, this isn't it. This is where Doc's note must have been. Okay. It was a 50-50
Not library goes deeper into the library look I'm just enjoying doing the games instead right the orange one
Had a careful. Yep. I
Need to be able to see the map
To the left this one
You waiting for stream confirmation mommy behind you the orange one this oops
It's not that one either oopsies that's not momos apart. Oh, no, it is Momo's apartment. Momos a boy. Oops. I thought Momo was a girl
Sorry if you're called
Okay
Behind the bars
Oh, wow, that's so obvious and I just completely patched it
She music the last one
Did you get it? Yeah, you got it. Okay shout out to all my momos a
Little silly and then the last drink
Know for the cans. Yeah, which where's the left can?
Can can can you do the can can can you do the can can?
Two more cans. Oh, sorry not pause. Um, I've got two energy drink rip
Yeah, okay
They need one more in a web says there's four cans I already bought a cat like I used the can on something
I don't know where the last freaking vendor machine is. I can't see anything
Highlighted like a vendor machine either. That's not been used. I've used one on the rooftop. So it must be like in something
One can for the cables yet if you've used one we're only missing one then yeah
I'm gonna go back over to that roof
Just because I didn't really explore that side of the map because I did the quest and then I was off on one
I'm on the wrong way
Did you get the energy drink 2k speed?
Yeah, I've got they're all 2k speed
Energy drink one outside Doc's apartment we have that okay good. I
Got one on the rooftop confirmed. There was like one I picked up from a rooftop
I got the main one that was right there, so it might whatever the one that's in an obscure places
That's the one I need. Oh, there's a memory over there. I can see it
Just to see if there's like any rooftop that
Looks accessible that I've not jumped up one. I
Think we have the rip human graffiti one
The one near Morse the music man
So like an alley that I've ignored no, I've got a suitcase for mom
Where's the telescope guy I've lost him
Is I'm not gonna try and go oh there is he's up there
Let's go
Hello, are you okay now?
My friend and I love talking tossing buckets at each other good clean fun or dancer neighbor disagree
So we're taking a break right now. Oh, I didn't realize they're doing it for fun. I thought they were working
The final energy drink location is on the rooftops of the slums to start head up the rooftops and find
Heptor
He's sitting on a little bucket next to a sofa
Near the robots for a chucking pain
Old man
Maybe he's up here jump
Wait
Is it this one
Are you hip-tor? No, you're swan. I could name those like real constellations a big circle of the ball
No need more brain-throwing. Hey, yeah, what do you want nothing? I'm sorry
The guy sat in the chair that you couldn't rub against okay
I
And then need to find that gentleman. Oh, please go up. Thank you darling
Okay, I faint him okay now that I found him hold on
From hip-tor hi hip-tor followed the little wooden ramp to the left
Look down to spot a balcony below you
The
Right the final vending machine is on the balcony, so make your way down
The ramp was immediately
Oh my god, that's so obscure
That is so obscure
Development team you should be ashamed of yourself. How is anyone supposed to find that?
At least make it possible if you're gonna do things like that
Okay, now we can buy the last memory
Shop we need the shop
Why some music go
Agreed that was painful to find I
Could not have done that I would not have been able to do that if you guys didn't tell me in spec
Well again, what do you want now? This is an ancient relic. I will cost three energy drinks one
Here you go, what is it?
Remember
The box were to help
This is an early model of a companion back then they didn't have any personality. They were just glorified autonomous cleaners
I think it's nice that the eventually mimic human is quickly missed them and in that way they kind of kept them from going extinct
They're good robots
Okay, we did it and then we'll go our last song. I don't know what it's gonna be, but let's find out. I
Don't know if we can make a song of it or if it's gonna be like hi
Oh, thank you for the music. I will practice you see
Yeah, I got the last one
Well done. Have a badge as a token of my gratitude gained an item. Let's see. What's the last please?
Petit vals qua qua vals en anglais
Petit small something. I don't know what vals is. Alright something small. Okay, we're gonna sing about something small. Okay, you ready?
Or does anyone want to give me the translation before I go to
Petit and then VALSE any
French refling
No, we're not doing SPH. That's for another location
Not one French refling lurking for Belgium is
French for the little walls. Okay, let's go. Okay a dance. Okay a small dance
As I slowly lean from left to right, I ask you please dance with me tonight
We sway together under the moon and together we enjoy our month of gin
It's already gone and July is here and I wouldn't have it any other way
Thank you all done
Thank you for all that. I'm a great musician now. Yeah, thank you
Okay, we're ready to go
Uncle uncle. Merci. Okay. I think I'll finish this area now because we did what we did
All right, let me just remember the old controls for the old light
Okay, I think we just loaded into another area and that's why it did that and I'm not about to be violently chasing
by a hundred of those bills
Hello, Momo. Are you going to see your friends?
Oh, I understand
I can't believe you found docking and no with this now we can go find zons of all
Oh, no
Will this dream be another seven every one? I'm not gonna 100% in this game now
I'm I already walked past like a few a couple of memories
Um
Stormi I have a question who in the fresh heck curse she be to become a muppet
What does that mean? I don't know what I mean
Oh, we're in a new location. Okay. I don't know what chapter we're on. I don't know how many there are but
progress question mark
Yeah, starting if you use the purple beam you get a heat meter
a reasonable length stream by stroney who
Shebe's avatar is um, is she is she does is she's streaming not on her model lmao?
When the moon hips you're high like a big piece of high
So
She looks like a child's guardian character in stray the sirre section is found in chapter six of the game
Uh
Okay
Can you look on the other side sure of course, uh, right just look on the other side of the gate
Well, I can only jump on one platform. So
I'm gonna jump through the bars. Dang. I've got skills
Uh, huh gets up from over here. Don't think I don't see your devious plans video game. I can read right through you
go across up and across
And basically three more chapters to go. Oh, we steam it. We steam rolling
We jump straight
Yeah
right in front
Uh anything up here
I don't want to jump down in case it's not
Came to jump down. I know I'm about to get jumped by those xx. Sorry video games
But you make it too obvious. How do I open the gate? I'm a cat
What buttons am I supposed to mash to open? Oh, I see the lever behind the xx
Mm-hmm
Just do it
Exactly get out of here
I knew it. I knew you dastardly planned
I knew your plan. Oh, no
Oh, no, it's can be. Oh wait am I safe up here? Oh my god. Oh my god. I'm so smart
Take this. Yeah, that's right. We can do better. Mmm. You're gonna pop
That's right
I can see your video game. I know your plans. I know your development team. I've played far too many video games to be
To be outsmarted with such dukes. How do you meow? That's right. Exactly. Mm-hmm
Not one enemy in sight. I'm just
How do you even insult me? Are you gonna pick me up, please?
Please pick me up
Meow, please pick me up
Can I jump on you jump? Okay
I don't understand if I don't directly talk to you and the thing doesn't translate for me
Johnny you always make us
That has to smell so bad
What smells worse me when I'm pheromone maxing or like
Exploding when coming into contact with uv raises that replay
Bruh rump maxers any rump
You got them good meow. That's right. I'm supposed to be meow
Hey, what I can't even do
Are you gonna jump on me?
Don't think I don't see you. Are they gonna jump on the boat? You better not
Is it actually warning us it's about to jump down?
Or is it just welcoming us into its domain? Okay, I think it's just welcoming us
Okay, let's see
Good good new york meow. That's right. Okay today. We're playing story
and
I'm a cat
I've got a uv array
You stop jumping
You stinky stinky
Zerks be like this is our tour
Hey, get out of here
Hey, mr. Jay
I'm Harley Quinn Zores. I can't meow
Oh
Uh, what's the situation momo?
This is old machinery is broken now. I think we can only open it manually
We
Do you mean open it manually we're about to get jumped, you know that right?
You're just walking them all up getting that boat. Is it me about to get jumped?
I'm so even though we have protection. Oh wait. Oh no, I have to go on my own
It's the end of the ride. Oh, I need to go more. I'm sorry. He's holding it open for me
Uh, I can't go with you, but uh
I won't stop looking for a way when you find zanzibar and clementine tell them I was brave. You're relax momo. You're not dying
If anyone's dying, it's fucking me. Look at this place
Oh my god, it's not letting me run
Why would you not let me run?
Don't do such things on me
Maybe one month we won't we'll beat the peeler allegations, but this month is not that month
Thank you for the tip really legend
Why why are we peeing on main? What's going on?
Um, wait, I can't go in that. That's murky water. Wait, so what was I supposed to do here? Is really a secret?
Can I pop these?
Um, was there even anything?
Wait, no, this is the dead end. Is the water shallow and it just looks like it's not or am I going crazy?
Yeah
Uh
Were they gonna pop as I walked past I think
Remind me who started the allegations. I actually don't know
No, we must move through the stagnant pee water on a plate. Look at the menacingly looking at me
They don't know that I'm I've got a strap. I'm built carry. You know, I'm saying I'm carrying right now
No, no, no, I saw it. I can see a bend. It's a secret. It must
Yeah, you better be better be watching out for me. I'm a jumpy
I'm a murder you and I'm gonna make a little like an accident
Okay, these are active
Hold on
So like how their butts get open
Wasn't that in me with her drinking stream where chat blackmailed her into recording that is that where it starts?
Oh
My my little sister isn't so innocent anymore. She can
Okay
I didn't mean to activate another one but fine. It's fine
Try not to overheat it too much
I can do it like that and just kind of see someone as they come
I
Think emmy is more likely to do it and she be no different not that one
I know it was just sort of a throwaway line, but I can't get an idea of strongy pheromone max and out of my head
Oh, it's because I'm fucking minion. Sorry, but I'm like an absolute like knee. I'm not being funny
Like I didn't go outside if I don't need to go outside. I don't like
I kind of discussed I don't even know if I should talk about it. You guys will be like so disgusted by it
but like
I don't even wear deodorant because I'm gonna go outside so it's like why it was the point of being deodorant
Um
But I hope my dad's not mad at me when he sees me
He's gonna be like strongy. You're like shit and I'm like, yeah
Oh, come on literally one
I
Hope one of the upcoming emotes is sniff. I mean if you want
Uh, I've got more than 10 like emotes slots
Unlock how many heart mojis are there like what's the highest number it goes up to because that's how many emotes slots are unlocked
But I'm not nice. There's so many
15 okay, so I'm getting a batch of 10 and then I get an extra five and then if I make more then
You know
Yeah, I know I'm definitely open to that
God this place is like
Well, there is this how you're supposed to tackle these areas just this feels like cleaning simulator now a little bit just kind of like
Oh, oh that guy popped in with
The hunger for the cat flash is okay the last couple of years from brothel everyone
It's not even that I tried to be mingin or anything, but I just I'm mingin
Like when I'm like when I say see is like, oh, I've not showered in a few days or whatever. I'm like, it's not a
Teehee. I'm so gross and nasty. It's like no, I ain't showered rough a fucking reek
I got be all out of the wazoo
I've got greasy hair out of the wazoo
That's a little it
Yeah, if you don't sweat it's pretty okay
Oh, no, I'm ready. Sorry, but I'm actually ready for you guys. I'm not being serious
I
I'm so ready. I'm not scared anymore. I can hardly see anything by the way. I don't know why there's like a duff freaking
Filler and of course it goes away the moment I complain about it because why wouldn't it?
Okay, let's just let's just go next
Yeah, that's right. You can't scare me now
You can maybe jump scare me around a corner, but that's about it
I
Whoa
Where are the eyes?
Hold on. Hold on. This seems like a bit much. I don't think the torch can handle all of this
There's no way I'm supposed to be being seen in Dungeon Mad down here
Oh
Oh the game's lagging because it's loading a new area, right that's manageable
Wow
I
Stony really gets stinky if I am I'm literally turning us all into Napoleon dynamite
Can I go through here?
I'm coming back in three days don't want
God it really does not oh the eyes are asleep on the wall
I can't do anything to the eyes. Hmm
I have to wash my hair every other day, but we don't seem to wash it off
Oh, I used to have really greasy hair
And I would have to wash it every day like I'd wake up and it'd be fecking greasy and smooth
But ever since I've been using lush shampoo bars, I actually get like a couple of days with it
And which is really nice
Um, so I can't recommend lush shampoo bars enough to be honest
So if you're ever if you've got the money to treat yourself, it is a bit more expensive, but like
As far as I'm aware they they pay their employees a bit more decently
Or probably publicity stunt. I have yet again fallen for you know, have you?
Um
Oh
No, do not tap it. Okay. Sorry. I'll just test them because I keep overheating the poor guy, but
Just the should men use it. Yep. It's just a generic shampoo bar. It's called jumping juniper on the lush website
It is literally, um, you put it on your head as you're in the shower or in the bath
And it lathers up and then that's you dunzel. Um, open the door though
Oh hacker man, we're in
Oh, we've done it now
What the
Oh
Is he gonna send an up? Okay. Yeah, he doesn't like it. I don't like it either
Oh my god, they just send more what the
break
Bruh, bruh, no, no, no, that's outrageous. Sorry. That's outrageous. Yeah, no wonder I'm fucking dead. What the fuck was that?
I
Saw is that was outrageous
And it reloaded all of those freaking egg sacs that are in my way, so I need to destroy them all so I can get a clear
And I'm gonna overheat again
I
Huh, right, so what I need to do I need to be able to wait. I can't even run across there super easily
I have to go down here and do a u-turn
That's ridiculous
If you're gonna give me a battery that like
I
At least make it last that's all I'm asking seriously
If you're gonna give a weapon to defend yourself, then you make like some fucking stupid ass
map like that
I'm sure there's probably some tactics I've not figured out yet, but that was really annoying
That was like, okay. Yeah, just keep sending it. Okay, great. Thanks
All right, let's hopefully we don't mess up this time. I'll start on this end because why not and what difference does it make?
He's already awake
Hold on. Sorry, I'm tryharding. I'm actually tryharding
I'm actually fucking tryharding and a fucking cat game. Please open the bloody thing
Wait, I could just use these barrels and jump across and I've been done
I was those barrels not available
Go right. You don't have to tell me twice to get the heck out. Oh for
What and the F
Hey, I'm feeling a bit intimidated as well. I ain't gonna lie
We are being perceived
I
Uh, oh, please don't cut to me. Please don't cut to me. Oh, I cut to me and cut to me
Oh
I cut to me. Why did you cut? Why can't I not just have been a cute little cutscene?
Well, I've been to if it was just an adorable little cutscene of how fast I can run and I didn't have to do this section
Oh, wouldn't that be adorable? Oh, that'd be so kawaii-ne, kawaii-ne, kawaii-ne, kawaii-ne, so kawaii-ne
Kawaii, kawaii, kawaii, kawaii, kawaii, kawaii, kawaii
Oh
I'm literally just spam and be an anticipation of them launching onto my room and butt crack
Please
Please don't make me frickin go back. Don't make me do that again. Oh god
That was awful. Can we get an upgrade on the duration of this little bad boy, please?
Wake up. Don't leave me alone. Please. I'm too scared to play this game alone now that I have you
Literally be 12 more like be reflin get it?
It was dark. I was alone. I felt like I was back in the network, but you saved me
Thank you friend. Enjoying that much power was rough on my core. The defluxer is completely
I was just praising this game for freaking not having to run away
I'm stressed. I thought this was supposed to be a cute cat game and I'm so stressed
Wait, you didn't hack it. Oh, you did hack it. Hold on. Oh, let's go before the fan goes on
Right, so we are
It's a flying refling. Yeah, you're literally gated me through the game. Yeah, yucky toxic
Okay, we can't say remember we can't say we can't say
Oh, hello friend, that means no enemies. Hello
Oh, hi, yo
A traveler from the sewers you haven't seen one of you in ages. Are you the one who contacted? Yes. I'm little
Zanzibar the outsider has been expecting you. He's meditating at the top of her village
Whoa
Huh
Wait, can they see the can they see the sky? Oh, sorry, we're gonna cut scene my apologies
I am sure that would be the last of them surely copium
Uh praying that the fluxer can be fixed the machine the scientist I insisted used one of these
He was sick. This was the last hope he walked into the machine, but I wasn't with him. He was alone. What was he doing?
Cryopods he uploaded himself into the computer and then everything was different
The
Bots aren't bots at all. They're humans
But the upload something went wrong. He was stuck for hundreds of years until a little cat appeared you
You're a human in a bot
Oh, no, he got a dolly zoom effect. It was me. I was the scientist
I was human
I need a moment. Oh, you are human
Maybe the world was dying so you had the choice to become a ball
Hello
Oh, you're covered in paint
Scratch board
Hello, oh, what are you playing?
What is this? Mahjong? Mahjong? Oh like they've got a little spot for me to play. Can I play?
I'm so sorry. Oh, no, I'm so sorry
Are you actually mad at me? Can I make it up to you? Can I rub against your leg? I'm sorry
Oh, no, they're actually picking up the pieces. I'm so sorry
Sorry, it wasn't my intention
Member? Oh, we've got a member
You render scrabble? I'm so cat-like. I'm sorry. I
I need a moment. I don't feel like talking right now. Okay
Yeah, that's probably a lot to process. I'm not gonna lie
That's a unique tea tree top. Maybe we don't need a farm roof lens. Maybe we just need a tree top
And we can all have different levels and stuff. Although I might get a bit chilly. So I think we'd I think maybe the farm would keep us warm
I think a tree top open like this would be too cold
What else have I forgotten?
I must have had parents friends. What happened to everyone? I wanted to open the city
But is there anyone else left to save? Oh, don't doubt your mission now soldier. Oh wait, we need to find this, sorry
Zanzibar, we need to talk to you friend wherever you are. Oh, you're bloody Zanzibar. He's a hippie
Oh, they got the fortune cat teller
That's it. I'm getting Chinese. Where's my Chinese auntie? What is this?
I've got a jump scare
Eh?
This is Zanzibar. Hey, don't you know not to interrupt a fellow during his
Transcendental
Meditation. Oh, it's you. You're with Momo when we received that call earlier. I'm glad to meet you at last little outsider
Eh, that's in you. You know Momo and Doc. So you're already familiar with those outsiders. I miss them. Their memories bring me peace
Momo stayed in the slums. I heard you helped find the doctor and clementime
She's in midtown now. If you still want to see the outside
She's the one you can go to
You that can get you there
Apparently she had some kind of plan to leave the city here. Now take this. I wrote her address on the back of this picture
Okay, I'm sorry. I just teared myself in on that mono-controller hydration check
To reach midtown claim up our little village. It should be easy for your oh for a dexterous one like you
If you manage to reach the outside you will be the very first. I wish you good luck, but you don't need it
I believe in you. Oh
Does he predict that we make it?
I'm sorry for shutting down earlier. I'm human probably the last in the world
Now look what's left of me so much has come back to me. How much have I forgotten?
Maybe if we find clementime, we can restore my memories and get you back home at the same time
We can go back down and find out more from the companions or head onwards
um
I think we just press onwards to be honest
I know you can
Someone said you can a hundred percent this game if it's like just hundred percent with memories like
Sorry, I've gone it. She knows
The Japanese golden cat also known as the beckoning cat typically depicted as a cat with one piece
Paul raised believe to bring good luck and fortune to them
Oh, we can play darts
I'm thinking it'd be a bit hard. I don't have a poseable thumb
Hi
What we cooking back here good-looking all the boulder recipes. That's so smart. Honestly. That's so smart
All right, you ain't getting that idea. I don't even
know
Uh, where was that ladder? I just saw other
It's also just nice to chat with the people if we aren't going for a hundred percent
Maybe I should maybe I should be a bit more social in this game
Okay, let's talk to the next person. Oh, you're a gardener. You're a leafling
Hello, buddy. How are you? Did you know that aunt clementine taught us how to grow?
Special plants that can live without sunlight. I have a huge collection. Do you want to see I still miss some of the colors though
I miss
Seeing a yellow a red and a purple. It's only someone small and agile. Okay. Okay
I get it. No, I don't think I can get it for you
There are you
I'm bored aunt clement used to hold classes. We learned so much cool stuff. Maybe you'll learn anything now
Please
Don't you that made that noise?
I hear in that I'm getting trolled by this game. I guess if I claim up that's not where I'm supposed to go
There's a bucket of paint
Wait that's how we're coloring the flowers with paint
Anyone let me go across
Oh, well, no
You want paint?
Is this um, I just trash in the place because I don't understand what I'm doing
Up up
Oh, that was the last the food I could talk to
Literally the last tip. I'll be more social the last two people. Bye
I'm not getting you your flowers
Uh, we're getting a bit dangerous. I don't like this
Please be careful little munchkin. You're making me nervous claiming this high
Okay, okay, I see
Knocking things over because she can I have become one with the cat
I know I'm not fired because I say meow that's not how it works
Uh, okay, it still looks safe. Is there like any
Memory things behind this video games love to spawn you in and be like oh, there's a hidden thing by the way
Right behind you. We've made it really obvious. Oh, please no enemies
Okay, I don't see the orange yet. I just see orange clore
What's the daily over in a subway subway? Yes
Tell me what's up. Tell me what you're remembering. You remember going to work
Look, this is the subway station. I have completely forgotten this kind of transportation existed
You could write to anywhere in the city people used to take it to go to work
I used to take it to every morning after saying goodbye to my family at home. So you do remember
I remember I was doing this for them, but they're gone now. It was so long ago
Yeah, that's probably really rough waking up and being like all your families pop off
They wanted to see the outside, but does that even matter anymore? What happened to them? What happened to everyone?
I think it's all went into robots and all robots were technical demons
I don't know
Anyway, we're near midtown now. Let's find this climbing town. We have a picture of her
We can show it to some of the companions around here. Maybe the point is in the right direction
Wow, okay, we just need climbing time
Wow
My beloved furry tripper. No, no quite
Can we tell the train to go? No
Chichi out my own meow meow
manned machine off line
This is a dead end that kind of feels like one. Oh no, it's not
You know, Q. 3, 6, then new school. Wow. Hello
Oh, wow, what is to remember here books, history
There's so many books here that
Charing test literacy the ethics of artificial intelligence. I recognize some of these that I have a library
I remember nothing was quite like the smell of books as a kind of page
It was a feeling almost like comfort a book was like spending time with someone
That's a you know. Whoa. I've missed that many blue memories. Oops
Little are you doing talking as long as you're happy and you've been to me don't you mom then
We are get to go. Oh, why are you jump-scared me like that? Whoa
What's going on here, there's evil robots
Oh
Please stick to identity corporate or we will have to transfer you to jail and repo key. Oh
No, I hope I can get a freaking sniper and snake those guys. They look like bad news
question mark
Translate
Ascend to lower levels is restricted due to organic life hazards. Please keep out this area
Oh
So the closed off because there's the thing on the phone. Hello. Hi
I'll go on achievement for nozzle off against five robots me
Do you hear that down below that ebb that flow?
The city haunts me it taunts me. Are we wrapping right now?
Oh climb in time. Yeah, I used to hang out with her, but she wanted to leave
She was a breeze and then she flew she's a wanted person now and too heavy for me. Hear that that ebb that full
You just wrap into yourself
Long as you're happy right so you know of climb in time, but she's not vigilante the other one
Wait, how is she a troublemaker? Is this city suppressed?
Bones are can I get into the nightclub, please?
Man, I'm one in I
Might be a pretty cat, but I want some boost. You don't think oh, I thought it was gonna be a Google
Dancer robot
Hello
Right, so those security guys are bad. Can I pull the machine to know I can hello
Sorry shops close I'm waiting for the delivery guys, but it seems like they're taking their sweet time
But this hmm. What's that picture? Oh, I know her. She's one of the people who's all obsessed with the outside
Oh, I thought this is a barber. I guess it would kind of like that. Hey
You know work it work his works. Let me don't lose your head about it as it comes ahead on the table
Ouch that hurt. What's that weird feeling?
Oh wait, I just noticed I've got buttons on my backpack
I've got the music button on my backpack. It's a reward. It's like a reward for exploring. Oh
Okay, this is red so we go in here
People there's so much people to talk to someone at the bar, no
Trip the citizen trip home I
Can trip them up?
Hello
Oh, this is
What will it be today our world must seem gigantic from your eyes which I could be as tiny as you
I've seen this girl before she lives in the residency
Hmm
How did I trip people up?
You
Sorry to pick on you I need to trip you up
You okay life is boring since the sentinels put cameras in her residence
Hey dumb face we can see you too
Wait, they can't do anything
Hey, the tapes are ours. Don't you know not to steal I could give you one, but you have to do something for
Jane ma Michael and me sentinels install three security cameras. We don't like that. Can you get them all for back?
Um
Wires, okay, I've got one wire here, but it doesn't go anywhere
Okay, let me cook give me a second. Let me let me let me look around. Is this the staircase? Oh
My god, it's 1984 a yakitori restaurants type of Japanese ears. They shall eyes and chicken skewers. Yeah
What's this? I can hide in a box all this
Oh
Me when I'm one minute late for stream
I was here all along I was waiting for the kettle to boil
Okay, how do I rip out the mainframe of these cameras?
Can jump on that
Am I breaking it?
Okay, I got one. Ah, okay, I understand. Okay, that's a crazy. Okay, there's one over here
Jump up and then jump on it
Jump off it
Where's the last one
I want crazy a little
Must be behind that tree the tree must be covering it up. I can't see it one second. Sorry
If we see a big box at the convention, please um
This is one
Sorry, I think I'm gonna have to go to the ground floor. Oh if the game would like me first floor on the wall
Wait, hold on. Let me check. I need to it's fine. I'm not gonna lose any time by checking out where it is
But
Am I gonna mental
Like up up
First floor on the wall, so this is the ground floor unless you're American wonka
So you're American that's ground floor. Okay. I was gonna see I was like, okay first floor
Was it chilling somewhere? What's the red door?
Ah
Okay, it wasn't looking over the courtyard I am a menace about the good king
Never go talk to the buddy. Oh, don't we just go down this way? I
Get some speed when I'm running that's all I'm saying like
Hey, hey, fuck them up. Hey. Hey. Hey. Oh, this is one of them hang out. Hi Simon
Well done. I didn't think you could do it here. Take your prize. You earned it. Uh,
cassette tape, okay
Uh, what's up? Enjoy the song. You love it
Oh
Okay, is there I think I saw someone upstairs if we went up another plate stairs
Cat doing cat things. Oh, yeah
Yeah, there is like a really big. Yeah here
Oh, yeah here
Okay, we're never up another
No, that's just news. Hello. What's up?
What are you? I'm a cat a quadruped
Quadruped making cute sounds. I like the concept. Yeah
Do you know where this woman is? That's an address
It's just here
Oh, wait up up here one of these doors stop is that
No
Wait am I being trolled? Is she somewhere in this apartment block?
I can't scratch on any of the doors
Oh, oh, I think she might be this one. I've got a bit of a gamer sense, but you know the one that's barred off and
Oh
Mom
Climbing time
I thought you were a scent nevermind. Who are you? Climbing time. What do you want? Oh, it's climbing time asking us that sorry
Uh, here you go
Wait, so Zanzibar finally decided to send someone. I guess you're my new recruit. You're not very big
How did you even manage this series? I guess you must be pretty resourceful. I've been looking for a way
To the outside ever since I left aunt village, but the sentinels are always watching now that you're here. You can help follow me
We're going to take down 1984
Uh
Well
Wowie we wow
I've been working on a plan to use this old subway for a while now. I even have the keys to start it. Oh, wait
A watt battery an atomic battery
I know Neco corporation has one
Secured inside their factory. I have a contact who can help us infiltrate them. I don't know his name
He's the robot with a bomber
jacket
And a gold chain
Someone small and swift like you should have no trouble sneaking inside the factory
One last thing don't hesitate to ask for help the city's bill of information. Just stay clear of the sentinels
Bomber jacket gold chain factory
That's quite the mission you're sending this tiny putters on i'm gonna be honest, uh
Wow, what a beautiful
I would like to scratch my pose pose. Oh, I'm stretching the fabric. Oh, no
Can I jump that oh
Oh close enough
What do I do is this just all no it's all the cup
Oh, that's really meditate
Oh, they have candles and stuff
This is a cute little nook. I like it. It's very cozy. You must get dusty though. Oh, I can have a little cat nap
I am very tired. I recover my HP. Oh
What a cute cat. I thought this would be a safe spot to be honest. Okay hydration check replaying
So easy you found a secret oh
Oh, I didn't realize it zoomed out when you go like a for a little nap pick a big stretch
It better be hydrating dang right I'm surprised we don't all need a pee yet
How far does it zoom out? Is there like an end?
Or is like infinite zoom like cameo?
Oh
I'm just peacefully sleeping
Okay, oh, I'm yelled in my sleep
Probably so cute
A lot of lamps are different down here. Oh, you must talk. No, sorry
Uh
Down and then down
Then what's this a bathroom but robots don't need a bathroom. So
God everyone really likes plants. Uh, I like this
Kitchen nice little kitchen
And that's the doorway that you're supposed to use oh
There you on
Don't do that to me
Right
Okay, let's go downstairs. I'm to look for a guy and a jacket with a gold chain
In a factory
Those are very specific instructions. I have no AC and sweat and so much. I don't need to pee anymore. Oh wait
My eyes literally I was like, oh that burned my retina right at the back. You guys okay?
Hi
I'm sorry. I forgot where I put it but let's go play
I'll just leave these there. Uh, right gold jacket. No
A bomber jacket. A bomber jacket. I don't know what was that the yellow guy I saw right at the start of the city
You is it you?
Right
Oh, he's just a video gamer. I don't think this is for you, but
Oh, a guy wearing a bomber jacket and a gold chain. I don't
Know what you're talking about. I can maybe check the clothing shop. Okay
Clothing shop clothes clothes slowly sentin on you stinky thing
Hmm you look like a food shop
Where's the clothing shop?
Oh, that's a hat. I don't need a hat. Hats aren't clothes, right? They're like a different category
Oh, I don't like these bots. Okay, that's definitely not the way to go
Uh hats are clothing
That's the clothing shop. Wait, what do I need to do in it?
I need to get the oh steel jacket. Wait, why do I need to steal a jacket?
He really said you think I'm thick
Wabbins if you looked behind here for some
Some item that you want so bad. Oh my god. Wait, he's patrolling it now. Oh, that was a bit silly of me
Okay, well just because you're patrolling it take this
Fuck your new shake carpet
I don't distract him
Can I like break into his office and like start?
Yeah, this is why I think of you for not letting me thief even though I don't understand why I need a thief a jacket take that
Whoa
I honestly thought that was something else going on
And sir item
The drip pot wait, I'll play music
Oh my god, that was awful
That was amazing
Bororum bororum bororum. Okay. I have a jacket now. What happened? Hi
Um, you've been in the city below. I had friends there feety. I haven't seen him in ages
Oh
I can't show you an eye on me. Oh, this is active
Nope, I guess I don't need it in this section of the game
You cheeky pincher that base was good though. Honestly. We should look into that after hi. Can you help me?
I used to own a bar. It was the closest place around here until it took a
Until I got married robot style
that's
Both hilarious and
Even if this guy bums me out, he's my only customer. Try not scare him away for me. Oh my god
Oh
You're not really supposed to say the mean stuff, right
Wait, who helped me was it the hairdresser that helped me or was it a guy in a bar?
Uh, can you tell me what I'm to do now?
Oh, yeah, I recognize blazer weird fellow. He has beef against the knuckle corpse and say fire time
Which is weird because they don't normally fire people
Hmm
Yeah, corpus have a weird thing about firing people and seeing stuff
Oh
Why are we we were
Are we your sweetie, baby? Oh, we bushed nosing together. Oh, yes, we're cute. Oh my god
Imagine if I curled up on a ball on your tongue
Big stretch. Thank you for letting me speak on you
Okay, I need to help me. Is that a guy in a bar?
I can't remember the guy that helped me
Oh, that's the shop I nick from hold on. Let's not go too close to it. Where's the bar? He helped me
Oh, maybe you'll help me
They're vicious and they got my buddy. He's in for 350 years
I just walked near the elevator and I got yelled at by a cent and for years
I've told us that surface is on a habit. Oh, why just accept that fact, but why
We just accept this is a fact, but why can you help me? I'm not quite sure what you're showing me
But you should show it to my friend over here who happens to know a lot about things. He didn't relate me
He's not oh, there we go. I'm not quite sure what you're showing me. You should show it to my friend over here
Your friend over where?
I would die because very cute
Do you and can I get some of that some of this may I please have a six inch and
Uh, normal bread. I don't know what the breads are called. Just the normal bread. Um, can I please have chicken?
Uh mayonnaise
Uh cucumber sweet corn and lettuce, please
Thank you
What can I get for you little chef? Can you tell me can you pay me real money? I'm sorry. I don't have money
My ears peeked up
Where's the bar how can I not find it though? Oh, this is the bar. Hey buddy. Can you tell me where to go this time?
I tried downloading able
Oh, the guy wearing a bomber jacket. I don't know what you're talking about. Can you check the closing shop?
The hat shop does that count
If he's saying the same dialogue, do I need to go to the hat shop?
My a sub
I don't know what kind of bread they have at subway. I think they have right. Hold on
Oh, wait, your shop is opened up now. Whoa
Whoa, what's going on?
Nobody can enter the shop while it's being restored and seen incompetent those two are maybe a while
What's going on
I've been waiting for ages for
Stoopalachi to get back and help me restock these hats. His boss is not happy
If the guy's slacking off at the bar again, he has another thing coming the bar the bar. Okay, red
It's called our subtle
Subalachi
Met them think responsibly not like the guy in the back room. Is that a hint?
Wait, is there gonna be a guy here now? Oh no, he's your sir
You're drunk how did I wake him up?
Wake up. It's the first of the month
This is a little stool
Oh
Okay, I think I know what we're doing wake up. I said wake up
No, it wasn't me you have no idea what it was
Is he sloshed you can't go to work slosh this time wait
He did he gets worked by bottles and he just walks off. Oh my god. He must be steaming
Oh my gosh, are you okay?
The parmesan cheese bread is good. I think there's someone called Italian bread as well
um
As if the morning after isn't going to be painful enough. Jeez literally bald. Um, oh go away sentry you stink
What is he stumbling for?
Wait, wait, hold on
Oh, he's angry. Where have you been?
Oh, he's sweating he's sweating beats of alcohol. I'm sorry mate. That was on me. I'm sorry. I'm sorry mate
Uh
Okay, we're getting in the shop since this guy stinks and won't let us in
To be in cat or stuff in here. How dare you know what?
Can I just jump her what am I supposed to do?
Am I to steal
I don't want to get spotted
Oh
Okay, now what?
Well, I don't want to get ran over
I'm so skinny. I'm so skinny right what I don't know. Hi. Can you tell me where to go?
Oh, okay. Oh, did I just chop him up? Oh just by existing. I'm sorry. Uh my bad. Um
I totally yanked from that shop. So I'm not gonna ask for help. Hey, Ben sir. Can you help us?
Or is it still shut club schools? No, wait, I need your advice though. What do I do with this?
A brave I don't take braves. What is that anyway? No, you just tell me what to do
You will you tell me what to do?
That this merchant sold me a faulty battery the other day
No, he just pretends not to hear me every time I try to confront him
If it wasn't for the sentinels on patrol, he'd end up with spare parts. Honestly, that's not true
I was really gonna speak right there. Oh, he's not gonna move. I can do what I want behind here then translate
Hmm
Oh, I see it
I'm at them because I remember that too. Hold on
Translate
Oh, it's backwards eight five four two
eight five four two
Eight five four two. Okay
Inspect badge
Oh, I'm a hacker
Wait, why would he get a badge for booting up someone for stealing from someone? It said EO is not good. I got there in the end
Well, he didn't react
Hi
Um, I have stolen hello, can you tell me where to go?
I'd like one conversation
Hmm consider this tomorrow if you replace my arm with another robotic arm and then next another arm too
Why is this book how to be a ninja?
And then my body and so on until it you I've replaced all my parts and upgrades my software
Will I be the same robot? You're talking to them. We're getting philosophical. Hmm
Uh
No, you're too philosophical to tell me what to do. I see
Theus robot
Hello, will you tell me what to do, please? Of course enough. Oh, he's getting pulled off
I
Told you five times you all she can't run around like that as dangerous. Hey, this is the first time seen this kind of robot
You're so fluffy
Oh a guy wearing a bomber jacket and a gold chain. I don't know what you talked about you can check
A bomber jacket wait, so I'm to look for someone in a bomber jacket with a gold chain and give them the note
Okay, I can do that
I
Bomber jacket and a gold chain, not you wait you've got a chain around your neck
What uh truly makes a robot unique if it's ones and zeros can it so be duplicated
You you look
You
Yeah
I'm busy. What do you want get me in? Where did you get that? You're my contact? Oh, you're without my contact
Let me make it brief
You oh, sorry. Let me breathe my brain just completely just made up a sentence. I wasn't even there
Let me brief you about the atomic battery
The battery is powering the necocorp factory right there
But this whole area is restricted and heavily guarded. They check every person who enters and turns away anyone who is not a worker
Here's the knife
Okay, am I doing everything backwards?
Am I was I supposed to talk to him first and then grab all this stuff because I've already got it
I keep like stumbling
You'll never guess. Yeah, you know, I've got you this perfect
Yes, I have it too
I'll get dressed now mine turning around sure
I keep stumbling into the plot. This is amazing. I like this game
I like games that let you accidentally progress without meaning it. These are great a little snug around the waistline build it
Okay, hop in the box. I'll sneak you across the checkpoint. Okay, got it
I'll take it
Oh and sorry
The unintentionally speedrunning
I mean, I like freaking I like games that let you accidentally progress
Like the one thing I dislike about assassin's creed brotherhood is you don't have access to the entire map
Which is frustrating because it would be nice if you could do like all the borja towers in one swoop
But you would be very op at the start of the game
But I like games that give you access to the full thing and don't like hold back or anything
Oh
I'm being inspected hold on inspection ASMR
Okay
Oh, there's freaking robots I can see me hold on
Oh
No, right. Okay. I understand. I understand. I understand
I'm in a box I can hide in there's one right there
Oh fuck send it send it
Hiding the box I need to see okay. That was lucky
That one on the bridge is blocking me
Oh
I see the barrels. Okay. I see the barrels my apologies. I see them to the left to the left
Oh, uh, no such thing no such thing
Hey
Hey good thing you're here. You can help me
I lost the keys to this place in the dark and huge factory
The senators refused to help me. They told me if no place to go more work here
If by any chance you could help me find that might be so grateful. Yeah, cool. How far did you drop it?
This place is very
Oh, no
You just do the same thing, okay, okay, okay
That's water so we can't do that hold on wait, how'd I get down?
That's too big of a jump for my little ankles. That's water so I'm gonna drown wait, hold on
It's over here. Oh, I see a jump. Okay. I see a jump
Right, so what is going here achieve a lever? Oh
Oh
Unlocked more sentries
So real let's play or choose how you want to play just options for handholding. Yeah
I can't get back
I can get back on this side
Yeah, so I can be detected a little bit
Okay, okay, okay next one and then run to the left got it got it got it
Oh wait, the sentry drones are to make sure the robots are working properly. Oh, oh, oh, oh
Okay
Or I guess or just eyes on the production line
Okay, okay, okay, okay. I was try hard in there. I'm not gonna lie
Whoa, I'm guessing I can't that tiny slither
Well, I'm glad he's stationary
That's tiny though
I'm good, but I'm not like it. So you think I'm kidney
Do you know where a pair of keys are? Oh, you don't want to talk to me. I'm sorry. He's hard at work. It's fine
Oh
No, the barrel stops us from getting laser beams. Oh the camera isn't even on
Oh that okay, okay
What was that
I'm in the headquarters
Stony trial try hard with my trial game. I don't want to step on
Oh, no, it's a puzzle
Turn on
Wait, what? Oh no, I actually have to do a puzzle. Oh jump over here. Okay
Okay
Oh, there's another one. Okay, okay, okay
How do I turn it on? Oh, I sorry. I meant how did I get out right?
Okay, so come yeah, and then you come on this one
And then you stop
And then you come with me
And then you'll lift up the barrel with your weight
And then I can roll the barrel over the fumatic tube type thing
Yeah, and then that's all three done. You know for a cat. I'm awfully smart to even have this perception
Stony move hiding in a box
The part we need can I just take it? Okay, I was gonna say um
Oh
Production line stopped
We're taking down the high table
We've got it quick. Let's go here through the centre of the shop. We've got this battery back to clementine
Is this about to be a run sequence?
Oh, no, we're fine. Oh
Oh, that's a smooth criminal
You've been hit there. Hey, you've been struck there
A smooth criminal
Where the heck is clementine
Uh in the apartment complex which it wasn't down here was it?
Or was it I spoke to someone around here. Yes
I need the beatboxer guy like the three guys at the apartment
Not there
Where wait
It's done there
Do you think the criminals eyeing my collection of vintage cars?
I don't know what happens
Nothing makes sense if we can't done
We're locked off right we're gonna have to go an alternative route
I assume is what this is pointing to
We're taking down the high-bot table. Honestly who would have thought the cat would finish through a John Wick started
I need to like climb off. Yeah
What is so neon
My little gamer eyes can't handle it right now
I really be oh remember, okay
This spot is nice what I wouldn't give to actually feel the softness of the pillows or the taste of a cold drink
This drone is useful, but I miss having my own body. I miss feeling. I miss
Hurting I miss being hungry. I know this isn't helping, but what if we stayed just a little longer? Thanks for listening. I'm ready now
Oh little buddy. It's okay
Is this gonna put me down it is
Hmm
I don't know how to get into this apartment complex. It's been cut off by the polis
To see police. I it's actually Gaelic
and Scott Slang
Polis is the same
Yeah, I'm just getting further away from the complex
Unless I'm to go up here. Hold on wait, maybe I was on the right track
Looks like I can climb up here question mark
Not
Unless
I'm getting very turned around. I'm pretty sure the apartment complex is like eight miles that way. Let me in
Let me in
I don't know what the downstairs neighbors are up to but keep hearing bugs on hammers
Okay, that's definitely the one I'm supposed to know
Can we go anywhere?
No
Can I go up on that?
Right, right. I'm in the wrong direction. Hold on. Let's recalibrate our headings
And if we can go down actually because I'm going the wrong way
I'll need to check out what the police are doing. I'll talk to all the people at the police the policemen
police
Oh
My god
Uh, right you talk with
Hey, you think you can stop us from handling hanging an hour and six
All this work for nothing. What happened?
I'm like looking for routes or anything but I'm being prepared
So does any reeflings know where I'm supposed to go?
There's bars I didn't there's no point in being inside it
I want to say I have to take a right because honestly the game was designed for me to take a right
Hold on or maybe I can like go in here. No, I can't
You're awesome. There you go. It's hard to figure out like what the game wants you to do when you're
Then you know where to go
So because like obviously we can't really use the light theory right now. I was like, oh the light will guide you
Really the thing's pointing them where I'm supposed to go
Danger
I don't believe I want to see it
Light theory isn't working right now
And none of those people are talking to me
The meow will gauge you okay, hold on
Yeah, I can't talk to you. I'll talk to the people in the bar. Maybe they'll tell me what's up. Hey, can you tell me where to go?
I've mastered every game that ever existed but can't figure out how this one am I not seeing the whole picture here
What game snooker
You need the you need the chalk is that what you need the snooker chalk
She's overthinking it so hard wait barriers
Oh for fuck's sake
Oh, there's sentinels hold on
Okay
Okay, what does it do?
Of course, of course the tiny cat can slip under I'm sorry
That makes perfect sense and I'll honestly
I
Just like I need I forget I need to remember like I'm tiny and small and adorably cute
You don't move right
Do you look away
You do
What about you I saw you I think I've got time. I've not got time. That's not where I'm supposed to go
Not here hold on have to use my brain hold on
Ready, where do you go?
Okay, it's giving jump giving jump
Not really a jump is it uh, how'd I go out? Oh
You move
You don't move okay, that's fine
Oh
Okay, we made it
That was a some stealth app that meant this game is actually really fair in its gameplay other than oh no, she's like what hello
Is she up there
She must be up there
Or she left me a note being like I've popped my clogs
Uh
Am I going crazy did I not just she left me a note
Look at clue. Oh god, she's hiding somewhere
Uh claim
No sign of claim here. Okay. Oh, what's that? It looks like some kind of a coded message
We're gonna have to play detective to figure out what happened to her. Look for b12 in the cat the answer lies in my stuff
And then there's four symbols
What okay, one's a lava lamp. I know that's upstairs the rock is upstairs as well
Wait that level lamps right there
I
Not that level lamp
Right the level lamp up here and spit is that we think
There's also a hidden message under the container it says I'm with okay
And then there was a level lamp up here. Okay. Okay. And then a level lamp up here
I was level up right there
Maybe not this level lamp in particular. Okay inspect
We need a belly last a huge huge huge laugh. Yes, they're coming
Um, this gem is a medium value in low purity. The glow seems to have been added artificially
Maybe it's the axis of beacon for us to find something useful bingo. Is it says blazer?
Okay, am I going crazy, but strongly seems tamer. Uh, I am
I am non-functioning sleep at the moment
I basically sleep for four hours after stream and then I sleep before our four hours before stream
Like I've not had a full sleep in a couple of weeks now, so I wouldn't be surprised if I sound not myself
So don't be scared
I can't believe it. My hyper reachable isn't hyper
Wait, where's the note? I can't I can't remember the other two objects. I'm supposed to find
No clue here. No, I know I'd what wait, what's the piece of paper?
Um a cone a cone
Inspect why not?
That's all right, right. You find something you don't say into the nature. I'm just clicking exit stuff. I'm gonna be honest
Oh, I heard the noise you bleep
You're bleeping at something I don't know what it's in this area
Sure
I don't want nothing to have an apartment. It's the way the companion see the humans. That's kind of funny. Oh wait the the cone
Like something it says come to someone. Okay. Oh
Right and then one last item which
What is number one a plant?
Is it in the kitchen?
Oh, you're worrying about your sleeping health. I don't know what to do
I honestly don't oh we love her. Um
I'm a bit
Mucked up
That's not a warren can
Yeah, it's definitely a warren. Yeah
I don't really know what to do because I basically pass out after stream, but I don't go full for a full eight hour sleep
So the only option I have really is to
um
drug myself up to force myself to sleep, but
I've done it a few times now and I keep waking up completely messed up and I don't do the full eight hour sleep
I
Can consume cannabis is it a plant? She's one. I think it's a plant. I don't know what plant though
She's wanting me to look at
Right you got so many plants in this apartment you can down
We'll go let me check one more time with the item looks like
What even is that?
A seriously is there a plant up here that looks like that?
I
Don't know what the item is
Well, that doesn't sound sustainable. Yeah, the space you're right yourself. Just sleep normally. I can't know that's the problem
I pass out four hours before stream
And I pass out four like four hours after I've already inspected you right the heck is this bizarre item
It's not in the kitchen is it?
Is up here maybe on the shelf
But it's a nice level lamp though. I have no idea what this is like was misread and sorry
I was also writing this message. It reads nightclub. Oh
What
Show me the image. No, it's gone. What?
It looked nothing like that
Nothing like I don't know what that was
Um, you sleep four hours and four hours just sleep eight hours straight and you're fine. No, the problem is I wake up
I don't want to get in trouble
I I can't sleep for eight hours is the problem
I could do the only time I get a deep sleep is right before stream and
Uh, obviously I have to wake up for stream
so I don't have like any
Solution to my problem
Because I need to be meman
I
Wait, how did I get over here?
Um, like obviously it's probably like oh just skip the nap. What? How did I get here? I don't
Oh, it must have been the wall
Take a day of rest without streaming. No, this sounds terrible. I know for a fact
I'll be so mad at myself for not streaming
That I would be so upset that I wouldn't actually sleep
And then that would annoy me twice as much
Um, that would send me into a fit of rage
Right, how did I get here? Was it you?
Whoa
Okay, he's patrolling. It's fine
Uh, are you sleeping then waking up looking at your phone? No, um, I spoke to my doctor about it
Um, actually a while ago now, um, and um
I don't like bring my phone into the bedroom. That's like a big no-no
I'm allowed to rot in bed like on tiktok or whatever, but I don't bring my uh phone into the
Bedroom because uh
it mentalates
The nightclub the nightclub all the bones through that was freaking hating on me. Yeah. Well now it's my turn
um
I'm the police is explaining that cat freaking stole it. Yo, let me in
It's not for you. We'll wait. Yes
A brave I don't take braves. What is that anyway?
Sorry, sorry, I'm not supposed to do that
I don't think the bouncer's gonna listen. Hey guys, I think we're gonna have to claim at the back
This
I do have maybe you could have some days with a gorilla stream instead
um
Oh, that's the window I can go inside
Are they talking? How did I get across to you?
As long as long term if you collapse with burner and I don't get burner like that I just get like can't sleep
Oh my god, you're so happy. Can I talk to you?
Oh, that's a shame. I can't talk to him. Oh as long as you're happy doing your thing
Hi, mr. Can I come inside?
Hey, how'd you get up here? You want to party with us here jump in and get a drink? Oh, yeah, come on buddy
Livian
Alex was the name of that mpc. I've just shot one of the person listening in right now
Whoa
What's this
Wow, I'm getting blinded. We're just climbing time. Is there like a hidden bit?
I've never been to like a rave or a party is this what it's like
Oh
Hey, wait, there must be like a private room that claims them like back here. Maybe
Clam wouldn't be in the middle of the floor, right? Surely not. She's literally a bit
Just sleep well on stream I far in my sleep. I honestly would if I could buy freaking far. Where the frick is claim? Am I going crazy?
Hey
Who is it blaze or someone or Blake?
I'm gonna say where is she you like my mask. I made it the jam the scent on the scans and it looks cool
You're a very shy dancer
Who wants to talk to hi
The access some private business going on it has been reserved for some blazer guy. Yeah, where is it?
Up
Up up
Uh, ask a new shop receipt. Wait, no, I'm still on site wait. I'm trapped wait come down. No down
Take it up
Hold on analyzing analyzing scanning location visualizing
Oh
Where there's wall here
God I suck at this
That looks like a walkway I'm supposed to get all the way around
How do I get up to it?
You see that you don't get rated on your birds
Once you open the floodgate with a farce it's over
You can never unfar again on stream
Wait, maybe that was the right way to go
Oh, it's it. There's not glass. I thought there was glass. Okay. Wait, so how'd I go up?
Okay, this has to be it
Um
So
Well, I uh, I think my dad's gonna keep me awake so I don't nap after stream basically because you'll be wanting to like go
And do stuff where the I'm genuinely stuck though
Can I like climb this wall with my claws or something?
I'm really turned around in this location. I see I see ladders, but
Oh for goodness
Use a lever do you guys have a lever here?
This is why so I can like interact with it
Hey everyone DJ Matty here, let's get the party started. Of course someone's been requested by a very questionable friend blazer
I need a record
Oh for goodness sake was it that simple?
Oh
Okay, it was that simple I'm so sorry
In my defense, I'm not smart
Wait
I need to do it on that side and I need a lever for it
There's nothing up here
Oh take the thing okay when the other guy goes what take his record
Okay, okay, okay
Surely that's what I'm supposed to do. I don't know why I'm supposed to do that
I
Right, I need to wait until he's not doing it and then yonkers record
He squashed him
Terrible
Can you snatch the plate? That's what I thought but
He's not coming over
This guy needs to come over and so I can steal the plate I think
You probably have to do that on both sides to take it. This doesn't even have a lever right? I need to find a lever then
Oh, where do I find a lever? Do you have a lever for me?
No
Whoa
What how is anyone supposed to know?
Okay, remember
Oh, there's no progress down here. It's just a memory thing
When I was human my friends and I would gather and party long into the night
Even if we had to suffer the annoying consequences the next day
It felt good to find joy despite the unaliveable surface and of a ruddery and the underground living conditions became more and more
squalid
And the capitalist greed of the companies like
And the police state created by the sentinels now I remember why we're doing that
Oh
Okay, so there's nothing
Wait
Let me in the vip right now. I'm on the other side of the door. Let me in
When I was human
Yeah
Everyone's been turned in my theory is that everyone's a human entire robot
But they forgot or maybe it was taken away by the state
So the people wouldn't revolt and accept that the surface isn't livable
Because obviously everyone's a robot now. So of course the surface is livable
Down with black rock. No, no, no, no, no the sentence is the high table
Down with the high table
Tin foil man, right where the thick is this lever take strange drink
I'm too alcohol someone
Why would I take a strange drink who would want a strange drink?
You
Who would want a strange drink the wink
Am I getting you drunk
I
Want to see you destroy that dance floor
Who wants a strange drink? Do you want a strange drink?
This club sucks when I tried to get that stupid VIP room. Can you believe it? I just stole this lever
If you give me a drink, I'll give you this off
Oh, thanks. Here you go as prom. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, give me that
Okay, we got there in the end
Doing it backwards as always
Okay, and then jump up on top of this one and then we can get away with it
Yeah, it wraps around
Oh, wait, should I do that music thing? Okay, hold on. Let me do the music
I think it must be achievement like make the club silent is my guess
No
Oh, wow. No, um, uh, I must be a I should have picked up a record somewhere
Yeah, well, okay. All right. Sorry. Sorry wasting time
Stranny is the master of solving puzzles backwards literally they're picking up all the random stuff being like
What?
I'm wondering if I'm supposed to bring in a second record and it like enhances and like everyone dances a bit more I guess
Is my gander at what is supposed to occur here? Please put me upstairs
Did he really just pose for us
Okay, what's going on here?
Oh light control let there be lights
Oh, no
Make that stuff low
Hello, can you lower?
No, no, no the other way the other way lower
And then this one
I'm in lower. No, you're getting higher
And then lower. Oh, wait. No, that's a jump across. I jump across now
Oh
Uh, I have to admit I did take a lot of time to get there. So I'm not even surprised. He's not just being chilling
I'm waiting for me
Hi, buddy
Hi
Are you just being teeny here?
I have a very good relationship with the sentinels. I don't understand why people complain so
You're the first that would be taken down
For your k your cranes you have committed against the community
I shouldn't have spoken to that man at all
Two birds with one stone, you're not as clever as you look little cat. Anyway, not in personal business as business
How do I blow him up?
We need Guy Fox's stuff right now
Business is money and I value money way more than our friendship or camaraderie. They are all yours
Am I about to do a quick time event? Oh, what do I do?
I just got a freaking laser beam
I've got an achievement all cat razz go to jail. I'm in jail. I got the jail the polis got me
The freaking polis got me getting me out of this cage right now
Why are you dangling me above a pit as well? What weirdos honestly? I'm just a freaking ginger cat
Wait, yeah, that's right. Oh no, I'm naked. Oh, I don't have refland with me
Huh
I need to get you back
You can't go on without you. It's too scary. I really am in jail. I've got the jail
Oh, maybe I was I don't know. Can I reach there? I was
Okay, rather confusing but I got the I didn't realize we were going down
Oh my god, they're torturing him
Uh, I need to get refland and get the heck out of here because what the heck can I claim?
Must be a claim and location is just jail
Look at the jail
Oh, I want you back now. I hate playing the game alone
You are ironically giving me so much courage to play
How do I get past you? You don't move. I don't get past you at all
I
Can
I'm not supposed to get caught. I can't that can't be right
Oh, wait, hold on. There's something here. Sorry
Oh, they aren't even here
I don't know when he's gonna come back
I'm just sending out. I'm just sending out seems like I can hide in here. I think you'll come back to me
Do you see just turn around? Okay, good
Very quietly
Okay
I go up there. No, I don't
I gotta claim up in this corner
Okay, here we go. Oh, no, we don't here we go. Uh, yeah, like that perfect
Okay, yeah
Look at that barricade in my safe
Oh
Hi, buddy, I'll get you
Oh god, that's right. We can't even translate we can't speak
That's called glass on it
That can scoop my boot in here
What's this
Why is the music ominous?
Please don't do ominous music. I can't handle it
Grab key
Uh, there's no shortcut. Let's go around that's okay
Okay
This is bleak as heck honestly
Humans are dead and had to be digitally uploaded
Hi clan drop
Hey use your hidden blade for your wrong game
Okay, now what's the plan? I still can't understand you though. I need refling you need to help me get refling
Oh dear
Help me get refling. I need my backpack
I hear that
I can't understand you
We need to be quiet
I can't understand
I
What are they doing to him
What are they doing to you they download in your brain or something
I
Don't I don't know point am I supposed to go for it you need point and tell me what to do
What
I didn't mean to get so ominous
Where the fuck do you get so ominous
I
Need me to go ahead because I'm small and fuzzy
Don't they manually jump over it? Oh, sorry
I
This is a bit much isn't it? No, I'm gonna have to go back out
Sorry, I'm like sweating. I do not want to mess up the sequence
I'm just a cat. Oh my god, please relax. Oh my god, please relax
Oh
I see the lever I see it I see it
We're refling I'm coming to get you but they're looking at you
I need to create some sort of whoa, what does yellow mean?
Attack on sight
Oh
Fucking give me that right now that refund belongs to me go down, please
Hey, how'd I get out here?
How'd I go out there go out the way I came
Okay, okay, okay, I've got my refill and that's all that's important
Feel the time
Steady
Okay
I
Saw that
Here I'm safe
I think I did it. I think we did it holy crap. Oh, please give me give me
Did they reset you buddy
Talk to me come on is it you
Let's go
I felt like I was trapped in my lab computer system again all alone, but you came back for me
I can't believe it. You're a good friend. Heck. Yeah. I'm a good friend
I'm so glad that we're all safe together again, but we're not safe yet. We need to find a way out of here
Can you open that door?
Wow
We did it we did it we did it
Let's get the heck out of this jail. I see a lever
sugar
Could I get in there or can I just jump up? No, I can't all right, let's go to last uh
Hold on the main biscuit uh, uh, hold on
Wait, you can't progress all
Neither can I
This has got glass. You need to break it for me. I need to go up
again
Throw a brick at it throw a brick at the glass for me
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you need to help me progress
A little vandalism never went too far
I can already see that. Why can't I hold all these?
Can you give me a lift up?
I can't reach you'll have to lift me please. Yes. Yes. Yes. Just like that
I'll be a second hang in there
Uh, okay, it's just a lever. There's nothing scary here
Climb spray base we're not, uh, leaving him behind
B12 gang
And I'm getting every comfort in my chair
The sentinels are broken the way again. They will spot me instantly
Maybe you can try and bait them into those cells and lock them. Oh, no
What do you mean bait them into the cells?
Only see one
Just him you want
Just one
I didn't know they freaking show at me. Holy crap close it close it
What's around? Oh my gosh
That really went for me. Are you okay?
Are you tall?
Wait claims you can't talk all
We're cat gaming today we pooding any putters you're my little pooders
One second
This per fellow seems like sentinels are ruthless when it comes to defying them
That's what I feared they have completely erased him no more emotions no more self-awareness no more memories
Please let's not get caught. No we won't
All right, what's the deal climb?
I need a lock of them inside here
Would it be better
I need to attract them both
I'm gonna lock it behind me
Wait, I'm an idiot. Oh sugar only one came in that's not what we want
Is it gonna push against the other door if it pushes against the other door
No
It patrols inside the dang cell
Unfortunate I messed that sequence up. Um
Right, okay, let it out and then do a little
Wait, was that registering it was inside? Whoa
One shot
Seriously
I fucking give me a fighting chance
I was gonna praise this game, but I kind of be honest with one shot death type stuff. That's ridiculous
Literally one shot. I mean I get there has to be like an anti like oh this game this game
It needs to have like it can't just be like super duper easy and all that but one freaking shot
Like me
I'm freaking gonna say I don't know if I did that in time
Again
So how do I get you in?
Yeah, don't shoot me again, I guess
And come inside I guess uh, this is not gonna work
I did it work
Oh, thank god. Yeah, the game was nice. That should not have worked, but whatever. I'll take that
You're a house cat. You're not built for durability. I know I'm a tiny cat, but brav. Give me a something to breathe like a lamb
Hi, you want to come escape?
Oh no, they took their brains
I
Juked him like a pro honestly, I was like, bro. I'm dying again. I'm gonna start region. Okay. Maybe I take it back
I was a bit heasty. Okay. I was a bit heasty
um
It's fine. I was just a little mad. I'm guessing we can't progress until I
Yeah
What are we looking at? All right out you come claim
Cat versus laser the cat should win it. Yeah, I should have infinite health infinite a ammo
This door it's only way out this jail. I think I can open it from that control room
We have to find a way to get access to that room though. Please look around
Hmm
There's parkour
Oh my god, what if the game just let me super easy just have a parkour moment with no enemies that chase me
Wouldn't that be awesome? That'd be amazing. Wouldn't you love oh keys?
No keys
They left the keys in the door hop on the back of the truck you should be able to jump over the fence
Oh, right. Okay
That's what I'm saying. I keep accidentally doing the puzzles. I'm like, oh cool keys. What do I do with it?
I was gonna like take the keys over and games like all right next great jump on back. Okay. I'm on the back
Whoa, whoa, whoa beep beep
That's what I saw a woman driver
Those poor saps are facing a fate worse than death. Mmm
Would you rather perish or would you like?
Rather like lose your mind but still be alive, but you're not all there
Oh
Please no run sequence
My heart can't handle it. I really can't wait. Please drive it. Please drive us in the car
Please oh my god, was that my freaking voice that did that noise? Did you hear that? It was like a piercing noise. Oh, I'm stuck
I'm stuck. I'm stuck climb climb climb
Wait climb you're not gonna pick me up
Hello meow
You forget about me bish. Yeah
I can get that I literally couldn't get that
Oh, we got like an actual cutscene
Oh
All right, come on, let's go buddy
You're not coming
Okay, there's no way we'll we'll make it out of the sentinels on our tail
I can distract them for a little but you have to go the outsider manifesto says we must go outside at any cost
I wrote that
Oh, that's so
You're one of us now. It's not that everyone has to get the outside
But one of us has to you've gained an item subway key now go. I'll keep you in my ram little outsider
Climb run yes drive away
That's so funny
Okay, come on you and your mechanic mess up now
Oh, our friend was here. Oh, no the hippies gone
And
Now that is a death
Flag if I've ever seen one
I fear you might be correct my dear rifling. I fear you might be correct indeed
Okay, we've got a subway key now. We're unironically about to drive a train
We don't put it in this box
No
Sorry one moment
Is it this side we drive? No
Um
I'm sure we got given a subway key
If the death is not on the screen, it doesn't count exactly John Wick 4 momentum
I read an interview by Keanu Reeves because I was so upset
And if he apparently begged the directors to make it obvious he had perished
and I was like
Because he didn't want any of our arbitrary ending
Um
So I guess the scene of him falling down the stairs was it
I think I'm maybe going back
Or not at all
Boo oh neko like no eco not neko
We're actually going to be a train conductor stop. I'm pretty sure there's a train conductor neko in some
touristic railway station in japan
The music's gone all funky. I like your funky beat logo
Uh, but he's coming back for John Wick 5. Yeah
Oh
Train conductor for gen 2 confirmed
Can I make a sec?
Show me you take it
Here's that paper
We already have a train conductor in gen
Is that an ac joke omega alone?
The control room the headquarters you say
Do you have a ticket to this
Just stick people love tree what type of train would I design?
The steam train the scottish stream
The steam train
Well this place hasn't been touched by time
Hello
Oh
They don't have personalities that on the surface enjoy the world's safest city waltz city 99
There's no robots
Uh
Waltz city 99
Things are out of order though. There's no humans here
But the robots haven't evolved
City sealed rules of confinement heavy prison sentence
City sealed
Wow
Greetings inhabitant of waltz city 99 the door leading to the surface is currently locked due to a confinement procedure
Please refer to any certified engineer inside the control room if you have any requests. Have a nice day
It's weird when they don't have a personality
They're just
Robots
Okay
Wow, this is weird
The control room is closed by some sort of security protocol
It says that only humans are authorized also says that i'm not considered human. Hey, that's offensive security protocol
Maybe if we work together we can open this passage way
Um the control
It says why
I'm pressing why but it's not doing it. I need to drag something over. Oh, yes. Yeah, I do. I remember this
Let's stand on it and see what we can do about this panel
Um, can we expect some gender bender and models females? No, I'm not like this
Oh
Okay
Yes, good little spreadsheet. Whoa
Oh, it's like
I can't scratch it off or open
Hmm
I need to throw something at it
Yeah, there's no gender bender of concepts that are already pre-established like
All the designs that have been approved so far like unique concepts. How do I open that panel?
Yeah, can I borrow your tool, please?
The savings you'll please refer to any certified engineer. Have a nice day. Thank you
Do you have a tool that I can borrow?
We started down there that was midtown and there we're up here
And
John makes and create with her coffee right
No, I was very surprised about the new gen two entry. Um, it completely knocked out a previous except the design
So that was a very I was very surprised. Um, because I had actually enjoyed the
Open human
I'm not sure what I'm missing
Oh, you know what you're actually done
Oh, yeah, that's right. A little cheeky like cold
Is it sabotaging?
Okay, this is my
Does I need to bring the thing over again? No, it's open
I
Chant to go to eat us through the high table. Oh, you've guessed the pot. How do you this is the control room for the entire city
They controlled everything from here and it's empty
I remember hating them so much. They had everything clean space limitless power freedom to move
Little good. It did them
The plague I remember now
Everyone was dying and they thought they were above it all they did nothing to help us
I watched my family die. I felt helpless. I couldn't do anything to save them
But I can still help you we can still go outside together
I will carry the memories of humanity and the people I loved
Oh
I think we did it anyway, I don't know. This seems pretty end gamey to me not to be dramatic or anything, but I think
That's it. That's the main computer
I
According to the mainframe no one has been here for years
The whole city is stuck in a lockdown cycle from long ago if we disable it
We should be able to leave we'll need to bring the rest of the systems online
These computer holds the data we need we need to turn them on
While you do that, I'll look for passwords and encrypted keys to get into that system got it
Yeah, understood
Okay, turn these on
I actually really like areas that don't have freaking anything. Oh
That's me turning it on by walking on the keyboard
Oh, I can turn the phone. Hell yeah
Oh, let me jump that
Okay
Let's go. Oh, I missed. Sorry. Hold on one moment, please
And then done
It worked good job my friend. I found it. I know how to open the city something's off here
Wait, maybe there's a way around it
Roof control stage
There that's the workstation to open the city, but there's several layers of security preventing us from using it
Okay, that's understandable
Now we need to do what we do best me. I'll hack the machines and you destroy some stuff. Yeah
Oh, we actually destroyed the high table
Oh, so you're hacking what am I doing?
This isn't destroying
Okay, hold on there's a symbol here
Oh
Get this off
Okay, I will do my job do gel. Yeah, take this high table. Okay, this one
In this room
Um
Oh, there's a second one. What are you? Why are you like?
Am I supposed to go up? Oh, the circus
Okay, and then last but certainly not least
This one right here, which is connected to this
Open it up and then say this
Oh, it's so cute. Yeah, fuck it up. All that practice
Did I do it?
Hack, okay, okay, I understand
Did you take HP damage? Ouch
It's not what it looks like
It's not what it looks like. Oh no, we've got to keep going. Okay. It's not what it looks like
It's not what it looks like. We're totally not doing a hack. Please quick faster faster faster
Wow, he's taking HP damage, but it's okay. Oh
I
Can recharge once yes, yes recharge will recharge you please quick before we get stopped
Quick quick quick quick
Wow
Okay, we're picking up get on my back. I think this no, no, it's not it's not
Just kind of make the workstation. We can disable alarm. Yeah
We literally can heal you you're literally a robot. I have terrible news. You're literally a circuit board. We can heal you
Rift control right go do your thing
Oh wait, there's
That's it. We're safe
Listen I have something to tell you I knew the power requires to disable the city
Control center would be immense more than the strong body could handle but never the security disabled
I can take control of the system and open the city overriding it would destroy my software
Um, I'm pretty sure the software is him
By made that choice when I hooked into the first computer
Is he gonna die I can't cry
I don't want to cry wait no
And the consequences it could bring
I'm sorry. We won't see that. It's like no
I thought I needed to carry on in the memories of humanity to hold on to the past but I
Can see a future in the companion than you here. Let me take that off
You are my friend my very bad. Oh, no, why why do they have to make it sad?
It's literally I gave him a freaking car
Mine is thank you. No, I don't want the conversation
No, it's literally I gave him a fucking car
Why does everything have to be so sad?
No, please
Don't make a sweet body roll on the floor
No
I thought it was a game about being a wika
What the heck
No, we're curling up for a rest next time
Away
Oh my god
No, like literally so it's plug them back in he just needs a wee bit of a more GPU come on a GPU is just a rock
We tricked into thinking it's literally harvested from the air
Oh
Why
I don't feel better seeing everyone
Do you even see the surface to make it worth it? No, don't put me back here
Can at least take them with me
Yeah, no, don't no, no, don't sit down. Can I not take them with me?
Are you joking I can't even take them with me. Why not?
I
Bro
When the hero never gets the good ending honestly
The city is actually open you can freely get in and get out
Why does it say like that this city is actually open? There's an old way to freeze it
Oh
Oh, I'm gonna see my buddies at least
Now there's pigeons and shit I can eat
And my friends here I'm calling for them
Oh
Wait, was that him
Was he uploaded into the mainframe was that him at the left?
Was that him
Despite that you're still just the cat
I don't like when you cry I fucking can't stand why do the games have to be so mean?
Why can't it just always be a happy ending? I mean like shit cameo is a happy ending
Like fuck me man
Thank you dimsy dan for the cat sticker the neck with sticker
They are just old home humans kopium. He took control of the system the drone got fried, but he's up like done in the system
Yeah, so there's their stray two coming out and then we can like shove them in a robot and then we live happily ever after
Oh
Whenever you cry it reminds me what a sweet girl you are. I literally cannae handle it
Like why can't we not just like fucking be pod champ? Have you ever played pokemon mystery dungeon?
I think so, but I was very young so I didn't understand what was going on
Wow
Wasn't a model twitching
I look like it was the rooms a bit dark so it's probably why
He lives happily ever after anyway if there's a straight mean he's gonna have
To struggle for it. Don't cry. No, I'm like
Why I just wanted to be like one thing. I'm such a crybaby and everyone like literally can't can't beat the crybaby allegations
Well, that just thought I was supposed to be like this cool neko game
Um, well, you know you're mucking about and like a post-apocalyptic scenario and it's like oh by the way the person
That you started with oh the parish and I was like, oh, thanks for that
That's really gonna brighten up my day after that. No, seriously that I'm so happy
That the person who helped me through the entirety of the game
Who helped me translate and speak to all the robots and gave me all this advice and we discovered that was actually a human
And they were a scientist. Oh, no, that's lovely that they just perished right at the end
No, thanks for that really really cheered up my day really made my heart speed up. Okay. Yeah, like
Cute crying mummy cup
I don't need to beat the embrace the crybaby embrace that emotion. Honestly. Why?
Oh, can't he handle it
Oh, but we love her crybaby. Honestly, it's freaking terrible for it
So out of 10
Honestly, I have to admit
That was a very fair game in the gameplay
my only
thing is
Maybe give a directional point to where you're supposed to go
Then again, I can see the argument for being like
Look, we've given you signs of where the shops you need to go and I kept stumbling into the puzzle somehow
But I do it. I think at the start we took a lot of time
I can hear my fucking neighbour in the garden right now
I swear to god if he puts on that lawnmower
She's sobbing hard. No, I'm no I'm no sobbing. I'm all right
Um our little crybaby seaweed. Honestly
At least the cat survived. Oh, no, I wouldn't even touch the game
I'm sure if the cat perished in the game like everyone I would have heard about it and wouldn't even touch the damn thing
Um
Now you can't even parley vu with the robots. I know
Um, are they confirmed that there's a straight to in production? Hold on. Let me check
Straight
Let's see is straight to in production
Not like you see it in the dark straight who is not confirmed as of yet. Wow. I'm surprised
Sorry, I need to sync up my mouse, but I keep them up, don't I?
Strony has been keeping the sea salty because of these games. Honestly. I can't stop greeting
We say greeting in scots. So yeah, Strony that was four hours. So I guess five hours is to 100% the game
Yeah, I don't I mean, I don't really know what you'd get if you 100% assume just as memories
I think they're gonna do a different game in the same universe. It is still a pretty recent game. Is it? Oh, okay
I just remember when it came out. There was like a lot of hype about it
because like no one expected that
So
Yeah, we're learning
That was cute though. Um
We'll just say it was 10 out of 10
For me personally, no, however, I can definitely see this appealing to the masses and being very fair
Like I think gameplay wise I messed up twice in the entire thing
And if I knew what was coming up like once I learned what was coming up, I could avoid what happened. So
Yeah, I don't think it's a
a wee problem
Stray came out in 2020. Okay. No game games take like at least three years development at this point
And I think in 8.5 animation and music was good gameplay was simple, but good story was good
Story was great
um
Yeah, I think that was
I think it's definitely on the higher for me personally. It's not a 10 out of 10
However, I can completely see where it's a 10 out of 10 for other people like
Again fair gameplay wasn't asking me to do like a billion different things at one time
I'm sure maybe exploring for people that enjoy exploring, but I don't really enjoy talking to NPCs
um that much
um
I know some people enjoy the dilly dallying, but I don't know for that game
I was like, oh, let's go to the net like let's do the next mission. Let's do the next mission
Like let's not dilly dally and like stop to talk like I guess cameo is a good example of like
I did the whole campaign and I only talked to who I needed to to get my fruits on that
This is definitely one of those games of all time from what I've seen I would give an 8.5 and I don't see a need to play it
I personally wouldn't replay it, but it is a good game
The game is pretty lore heavy, is it?
I think maybe yeah, maybe if you solo explored and you know
Read everything there was to say and found all the wee secrets and memories and that maybe you know, it'd feel like a bit better
Yeah gameplay wise it isn't that appealing. Yeah, it's I would say it's relatively easy
Which I quite I'm enjoying an easy gaming experience these days. Like I'm really addicted to baltro
But it's so hard not to like slam it down every week. So I'm behaving. I promise there's no baltro for a couple of weeks
Um, I've really been enjoying stuff that doesn't require like insane reaction time
Because that's like where I get frustrated. I have to like replay the same mission over and over. I do wish we had our
aim
A cutscene where all the cats got together though. That's a bit annoying. I like understand the cats freeing back on the surface
But I wanted it to see its pals, you know, like is that is that too much to ask for chat noir?
In a two tail polka dot. Oh, I forgot his name and cally-cally clear. I think
Stray is one of those
huge
Intractable movie type games. I'm gonna not even pretend. I know what that word. We should have baltro Monday. Nah, I've got
I've planned a little bit ahead of what streams I'm doing when my dad gets here. Um
I've got an Orwell game. I'm not even kidding. It's like a 1984 game. I'm forcing you to play it with me
I don't care. I honestly don't care. I'm forcing you to play with me
And I'm sticking a tinfoil hat on me when we do the entire gameplay
I need to start using like vtuber assets like this more because the ears are so funny
Interactable, okay. Yeah, is that a retro game? No, it's like a
I don't know. You just like click through the text and stuff
I'll read it out though. Don't worry. I'll read it out
But yeah, that was good. I enjoyed that. I'm gonna is there any uh veal or girly pops on
Yeah, I mean the review said the game takes five hours. So
Uh, I really be stumbling very luckily into that stuff. Uh
Is there any veal or girls on that I can redirect into just the question
She be on Elden Ring. Let's effin go
Let's effin go
Elden Ring it is time. Rise do you turn is she playing at the proper way or is harem
Is harem coming into help her or is she doing it the proper way?
As the development team intended, what do you mean you don't play Elden Ring as a multiplayer experience?
What are you talking about? It's a perfect multiplayer experience
That yours are cute. Read them up it. Let us go. Oh, no, somebody save she be. She hasn't summoned anyone yet
Oh my god, she's so brave. I'm like as soon as as soon as I had access to the summoning circles. I was like
Come play with mome
Oh also, uh all my thumbnails are up like all my streams are up for this week
We are playing the jellybean game, which is called fall guys. So if you don't have fall guys
Installed please do it for me if you want to play with me. I'd like to play with you. That's okay
But I know some people don't like downloading the launcher because I think it's an EA game
And I'm sorry if you don't so it's okay if you don't want to download it and play with me because of the launcher because I know it's a
thing
A real pro gamer not like me
Yeah
Some girls just like being princess carried in games and some like a challenge
I think a lot of people will show you in that game. Yeah, but the reeflings get to touch me and get to jellybean pull on me
Not that I had to make a new epic account
Hackers tick my your epic freaking account. Wait. Did you spend money on it?
All downloaded and ready to go. I just don't like fall guys
We were playing other multi game experiences
We're actually going to be making puzzles together
In a week or so, but I'm going to hate what I'm going to make the image
And I'm going to make it really difficult and I'll see if we can do it
A bit those of us who have on steam
I think you can like play with me. No problem because I just give you the code
Who would hate the fortnite launcher? No, it's a fortnite. It's fall guy
No money, but I lost some of the free games I claimed. Um
Shocking
Puzzles with Johnny. Yeah, but I'm going to hide the screen
So you don't know what the puzzle is and then I'll give you the link and then we complete the artwork together
Um
I had to catch up on Isaac
So I'm ready for multiplayer when you said this game wants you to suffer. Yeah, you're right
I remember why I draw oh the game does not
Want you to win it is a punishing game. Um
Like I honestly enjoy just playing it casually
I've not actually hardcore tried to go for any unlocks in a very long time
I should have showed off my unlocks because I had a I've got two
Alternative characters that aren't unlocked on Isaac and I keep forgetting to get them
But yeah, the game does not like you like I'm pretty sure pretty much all my unlocks are like
I randomly stumbled upon an R key. Um, and then did what I needed to do
Um, but yeah, that was like a really good experience. Is this freaking shame that I cried honestly
I'm such a fucking crybaby. Can he stop it?
Um, but that was really good. Um as for what I'm going to do when I go off lane
I've got two more ASMR collab scripts to write and then I have
Officially like given everyone what they need to collab with what I would like them to give me for the collab and then
I'm going to take a break from doing asking people for ASMR collabs just for a teeny weeny bit
Um, and then I'm going to focus on my
sub scraper milestone. Thank you videos. Um
And also the meme videos we've actually got the pregnancy ASMR comment that sounds bizarre saying that in a sense
I've got the pregnancy ASMR coming up. I've got hypnotizes you to like, um
Pineapple on pizza. I hope you can sleep. Yes. Um, I get I'm probably gonna go for a nap
But it's it's the only way I seem to be able to sleep that minute is go lie down
And then when I wake up I do a big chunk of work
Like the girls all had shorts come out today if I'm not mistaken. I think the mercy might have had a short come out
Let me see one more check
Um, I ordered a four for a zero one of them, which is absolutely hilarious. I cannot wait for you guys to see it
Oh, no, the mercy one must come out tomorrow. So it's only a season one that came out. Um, I
gave any to she is gonna upload it when she wants to upload it
and
Yes, I've linked the ac short if you want to watch that literally it's in the the the chat
A right now at the top. It's a funny clip. I was absolutely hilarious
It might actually be the first a clip on the viewer like clip channel. Um
We're gonna very slowly start putting stuff up. Um
Sorry, I just opened up Marshmallow just to see if anyone said anything the first sentence I read
One of the reasons I love you so much is that you can't spell or read
Refling oh my god, you're not supposed to say that. I mean you can Amy has a new one with her rats
Oh, did she post it? Okay. Uh, I will link. Uh, I'm actually gonna link Emmys
Tomorrow's stream. I will pin Emmys. I've pinned acs today. I'll pin Emmys main. I'm not really that bothered about
Wait hypnosis about pineapple on pizza. I missed that
Um, when we were meme I was memeing with the reeflings like in another stream
And I think I was like, oh that would be a really funny meme video like someone said it and I was like, oh my god
What if I did it hypnotizes you to like pineapple on pizza ASMR because like obviously I like my meme and shitpost day one
Um, or a little illiterate little seaweed doesn't know our abc's or one two three's honestly. Um
What was the rest of that message though? I don't really know why but I can't stop myself from wanting to squeeze you tight in my embrace
And kiss you on the forehead when you spell something wrong, especially when you get flustered over at a dory
I always have. Oh, thank you reeflin. I'm glad it doesn't frustrate you
I feel like when people like see how I type it's like, oh my god, how does your mind work like that?
but like I don't I like trying not be mean to myself about it because
like I
I think it's like a good thing that I show like, oh, I don't know how to spell so I have to spell it phonetically in my head like I have to
Do things in my head like a bit different the way that like you might have been taught or you do otherwise
um
So yeah, I'm glad it doesn't frustrate you and you have the patience for how dumb dumb I am
More making hypnotizes for all four and all she likes but pineapple pizza is too far
Okay, dude. You're done. So what's the plan of attack tomorrow?
um
Uh
What is what are we doing tomorrow my good figures?
Uh community posts tomorrow's plan. Oh, I'm gonna show you how I write a some more collabs now
It's slightly different. It's slightly different. Hey, but I'm going to write my one-on-one collabs with everyone in via lure
Um, sorry, I have snot in the back of my schnozer because I was crying
Um, and then I'm doing a membership ASMR. So yes, hopefully
The freaking neighbor doesn't start cutting his grass
And the members we love everything you do. Oh, thank you. I love everything you do too
Especially when you let me do certain things to you
I offer you an accord refling
Congrats on 9 000 subscribers. I know. Oh my gosh. I'm like so I'm in so much ASMR there
I need to I need to get my button gear, but I I think I'm editing an emmy and ac collab and
I'm going to put it in a unlisted on emmy's channel and she can put it live whenever she pleases. Um
But yes, I think that's my job today finish
a the collabs scripts
Finish the emmy and ac ASMR and if I've got any more fuel in the tank
I'll edit the sheebie ASMR and she can put that up when she's ready
Yay
After yesterday you aren't the dumb cutler fish anymore
uh
Steady on I am I am so
I'm a switch, okay
Stroney, you can do literally anything to me. You're not supposed to say that part out loud. You're supposed to be like, oh
Oh
Okay, I I'm gonna go and I'm gonna um
redirect into sheepsters. Um, I'll say hi for a moment actually. I really need to stop dropping and rolling
I'm like in alias this stream. I was like, thank you for looking after the reefing spy
I did a little chant and then I was like, right I'm out
Oh
Okay, let me pop open cheeky. Oh my god. She really is a muppet
Why
Please check out Toma keys who made my png for this stream
Oh my god, that's like you guys were meman when you were like, oh she'd be some muppet. I like what
She says, yes, I played this game before I'm doing a faith in and oh god, okay
Oh god, she's gonna completely have dimmy in this
Okay, thank you so so much reeflands for hanging out
For letting me get all teary-eyed a a freaking game about kitty cats and I'm yum yum yum
Yeah, I'm gonna redirect naturally into sheebie
So you'll be you'll be swept off your feet to enjoy her elden ring
If you want to see what real gameplay looks like
And not a crossbow ball from halfway across the map whilst I munch on my food and commentate if the reeflings are doing well
in the fight or not
This is actually real gameplay
Okay, thank you so so much reeflings. I'll see you tomorrow. You can't miss me already. I'm not even online
And we must provide hugs for mome. Mome is okay. I'll be okay. Don't you worry. Okay. All right. Thank you so so much
I'll see you goofy goobas
tomorrow
For some ASMR rating and yes, you're more than welcome to suggest anything you'd like us to say in our collapse
I will tell you what the plots are so you'll know what's up. Okay. All right. Bye. Bye
Uh a reefling. Did you forget you need to pucker your lips?
Ah
Okay, bye bye reeflings. I'll see you tomorrow. Senjian is she be okay without a big wet slobbery one. You're welcome
My but oh my my cat ears are so messed up. Oh
Bye bye